AI drives efficiency Innovation and
informed decision making across
Industries underlining its pivotal
modern importance child Deputy stands as
an example of ai's achievements showing
its ability to produce sophisticated
language models with this course we will
see what is chat GPT and how it works
what is GPT 4 top 20 chart GPT tips and
tricks how to use chat GPT with various
Technologies like web development
marketing SEO cyber security UI ux and
Excel the best part of this course is it
covers various tips to earn money using
chat GPT by the end of this course we
will have a minor discussion on various
chat GPT competitors like bad and Bing
and put a light on concerns everyone is
having where the chat Jeopardy will take
over SEO on that note if you are eager
to know how GPT is so so amazing what is
the intelligence behind such a tool and
how you can create one then you should
definitely look at simply learns Ai and
machine learning bootcamp acquire
Proficiency in machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning natural
language processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and more through an
intensive AIML boot Gap this
comprehensive program features live
sessions conducted by industry experts
practical Hands-On Labs industry
applicable projects and exclusive master
classes led by instructors from Caltech
so grab the course now find the course
Link in the description box listen to
what our Learners say about our courses
in their own words
meet John a talented programmer who is
looking to start a company that used his
personally developed mobile application
to connect restaurants and customers for
booking and reservations
even though the app was ready John had
difficulty getting together a team for
his startup needing separate people for
sales marketing programming content
creation and customer support
hiring reliable Manpower while being
strict with his budget was getting
difficult
he reached out to his friend Ryan who
said John could start his company
without hiring any new people thanks to
just a single AI based tool John
couldn't believe it which led Ryan to
introduce chat gbt the Revolutionary AI
chatbot being developed by openai
it is a state-of-the-art natural
language processing or NLP model that
uses a neural network architecture to
provide responses this means that the
chat GPT bot can answer questions
without being explicitly told what the
answer is using its own intellect unlike
previous AI chat Bots
so how does chat GPT help John in
filling out his team
regarding sales chat GPT can provide
full-fledged sales pitches based on the
correct prompts it can provide tips on
how to pitch your product businesses
removing the need for sales training
completely customized to your
requirements and your prompts if you
don't like some things about the
response you can ask for certain changes
and the chat bot will make sure they are
done when it comes to marketing chatgpt
can provide efficient marketing
strategies which can help new
entrepreneurs learn how to Market their
products to prospective clients it can
provide trending keywords that marketers
can use for SEO purposes while providing
ad copies for your website and blog
speaking of websites since John can do a
lot of the heavy lifting and programming
chat GPT can help proofread the code and
help out when looking for bugs to fix
apart from basic bug fixing it can also
provide sample code structures for
different programming languages allowing
John to focus more on improving core
functionality and workflow rather than
fixing basic code errors
websites and blogs content is very
helpful in gathering potential customer
leads
the Revolutionary bot can provide
full-length blog posts with near perfect
past accuracy in seconds allowing
further customization like choosing the
length of the subject matter to the
complexity of language
for John's customer support the bot can
draft complete customer service emails
based on the situation saving time and
resources
the tone of the message can be changed
to reflect the nature of the message
creating an efficient alternative for
call center professionals
John was left speechless seeing this
level of Versatility from chat GPT and
wanted to implement it right away
however Ryan made sure John knew about
some drawbacks of the chatbot before
getting started since the bot is trained
mostly on data up to 2021 many of the
newer events May still need to be
discovered by chat GPT even basic stuff
like asking about the current date and
time is beyond its scope much like the
limited understanding of context despite
providing near lifelike solutions to
certain problems even the accuracy of
many responses can be questioned since
the AI model is still learning and being
developed there is a section of the
public that believes the Revolutionary
tool can one day replace Google search
but that day seems far-fetched so far
because of the variety of issues people
keep running into and using chat GPT
however chat GPT poses a lot of promise
for the future of AI from full-skilled
automated divisions and organizations to
serving as the perfect digital assistant
open AI is creating a bot for the future
aimed at solving the problems of today
with the tools of tomorrow
the ability to carry out a myriad of
tasks with minimum Manpower will boost
productivity at organizations in every
sector thanks to the Revolutionary chat
GPT
so how do you think chat GPT will
benefit your daily life are you looking
forward to using the bot regularly for
work or personal life let us know your
thoughts in the comments meet John a
software developer John develops a
program and now he realizes the program
is surrounded by a lot of bugs
John starts exploring a solution
he surfs through the internet checks
programmer communities doubting every
step of the way John feels his problem
is not solved
desperate to find the solution John
meets his friend Adam
Adam comes up with the 90 of an
artificially intelligent and practical
solution called the chat GPT
Adam says chat GPT has the caliber to
systematically resolve all the bugs with
an elaborate explanation for every step
it makes
chat GPT is an AI trained model that
works in a conversational way
developed by open AI
fascinated by hearing this John asks
Adam to explain him in detail after Adam
explains that GPT AKA generative
retraining Transformer has come a long
way
before the introduction of GPT natural
language processing used to deal with a
specific task with large amounts of data
GPT was first released in 2018 which
contained 117 million parameters GPT
gpt2 and gpt3 each one is stronger than
the one before it
the main reason why GPT received little
attention was that it was more of an
idea or test than a finished product
but after the introduction of gpt2 it
gained a lot of attention as it could
accurately predict the word that would
begin a text
then they introduced gpt3 which is a
strong language model achieving
translation question answering and
Performing three-digit arithmetic
but chat GPT Stands Tall compared to all
other achievements of open AI so how
does it work chat GPT uses deep learning
techniques to generate human-like text
it is based on the machine learning
model derived from the class called the
large language model
chat GPT is a byproduct of instruct GPT
instruct GPT introduced a strategy for
integrating human feedback into the
training process to match model outputs
this Innovative technology made chat GPT
exceptional
it is trained on the massive data sets
of text from the internet and learns
from the patterns and relationships
between words and phrases it responds to
a prompt by determining the next word
based on the context then repeats the
process until a stop condition is met
as a result chat GPT can produce various
logical responses to various queries and
prompts the most important components of
chat GPT are the Transformer model and
language model
coming to the Transformer model it is a
neural network architecture designed to
process sequential data it consists of
multiple layers of self-attention and a
feed forward Network
after the Transformer model has
processed the input a decoder generates
the output
the decoder uses the context provided by
the encoder to generate the response
the model is trained using unsupervised
learning and fine-tune on specific tasks
using supervised learning for successful
completion of tasks it needs pre-train
data
the model first encodes the input text
then converts it to a numerical
representation which can be processed by
the model's neural network
this encoding is done using the embedded
layer that Maps the work
then comes the language model
chat GPT is trained as a language model
trained to predict the next word in a
sequence given the previous words
the language model intends to produce
rational consistent and meaningful
output
the pre-trained chat GPT can be tuned
for a specific task
so chatgpt passes a fine tuning test by
answering questions generating text
summaries or generating text in response
to a query
overall chat GPT is a powerful language
model with a combination of techniques
like deep learning machine learning
neural networks and natural language
processing
can chat GPT change a wide variety of
business tasks John asked
chat GPT possesses the ability to
automate content creation on social
media create chatbot and e-commerce
sites provide medical assistance by
acting as a symptom checker write code
and assist a developer
thus chat GPT can change the working of
every industry now John can resolve any
coding issue without looking into any
other resources
but like any other technology chatgpt
comes with a few limitations that can be
its Achilles heel
chat GPT is capable of developing
content up to 2021. it finds difficulty
in providing logical reasoning in
certain situations
and also chat GPT lags in Translation
summarization and sometimes question
answering but above all chat GPT has
shown remarkable ability by providing
accurate answers flawlessly in a
creative way in very short periods of
time
whether you attack Enthusiast a expert
or just curious about the new and
exciting development you won't want to
miss this discussion about the latest AI
sensation I'm talking about chat gbt a
highly Advanced language model based on
gpt3 technology developed by openai
chair GPT is a state of art language
generation AI model that has captured
the attention of millions of people
around the world it has been trained on
a massive data set of text Data making
it one of the most largest language
models to date but do you know a new
version of GPD is coming up it's called
gpd4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gpt3 now you might
be wondering what are these parameters
so what it means when a user sends a
query to the New Year version of stat
GPT then it will process that query with
all one trillion parameters to deliver a
correct and suitable response isn't it
mind-blowing not only that GPT 4 will
have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation text
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
Fable studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability
gpt4 has the possibility of being
utilized for additional functions such
as generating images and videos this is
due to the fact gpt4 is constructed
using the Transformer architecture which
has demonstrated Effectiveness in
multiple machine learning assignments
including computer vision psychologist
and cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that gpd4 will
blow the mines He also mentioned that
gpt4 will totally Eclipse chargpt as it
has more parameters and is being trained
with more data however the CEO Sam
Altman debunks false information
surrounding the company's upcoming chair
gpt4 Orman said that he did not have an
actual AGI that is an artificial
intelligence that could travel humans in
learning and existence
the release of chat GPT and other AI
powered chatbots had has a major impact
on Google search business with the New
York Times reporting that it prompted
Google's management to declare State
emergency referred to as code red gpt4
with its improved complexity and quicker
response time has the potential to
enhance communication by making it more
natural and accurate for instance short
sentence responses from a chat board can
reduce the likelihood of people clicking
on ads this AI technology could bring
about a major transformation in the
economy Google employees have been
assigned the task of developing AI
products with gpt4 that can match the
capability of gpt3 such as its
capability of generating art music and
other visuals that open AI is currently
capable of Microsoft has invested 3
billion dollars into the open Ai and is
reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as deported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of GPT 4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 22
three Matt mcelveen a venture capitalist
with knowledge of GPT 4 hinted that the
new system May possess his multimodal
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and songs the
gpt4 chat board built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to charge GPT
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam outman has cautioned not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what GPT 4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about shared gbt4 do let us know in the
comment section below now this shows
that AI is one of the most sought out
technology in today's day and age so
let's get started with the top tips for
beginners for using chair jpd and to get
started you will need to access the open
AI API so we'll start with the first
trip that is change your dashboard
appearance so for that we'll move to
chair GPD and you could change the
desktop appearance for Dash to code
appearance of charge debating you can
customize your dashboard by going to
settings and choosing a new theme or
layout so for settings
we will go here and in general you can
just select the theme that is light you
can change it to dark system theme or
light theme so these are the options you
can use to change your dashboard
appearance so this can help you create a
more comfortable and personalized
working environment for example you can
change the color scheme and you can also
change the font size also and you can
generally change the font size by just
zooming in the window
and the second tip we have is switch on
beta features so we have moved back to
charge repeating and here you can see
the beta features so for that we'll go
in settings and data that is custom
instructions try a new feature that lets
you share anything you would like charge
gbd to consider closets responses so we
have switched on these beta features the
plugins try a version of chat repeat
that knows when and how to use
third-party plugins that you enable the
code interpreter that is a version of
child Tubidy that knows how to write and
execute python code and can work with
file approach so asking for help with
data analysis image conversions or
editing a code file and these files not
processed Beyond a single session so
these are the plugins or the beta
features that we have turned on and we
are using them and in chat gbt4 gbt4 you
could see that is code interpreter beta
and the plugins beta they both are
available for us so this was the second
tip that is switch on the beta features
and you can use them that is you can
toggle on beta features to try out new
and experimental features if you like
trying out new features you can switch
on beta features there are experimental
features that are still being tested
keep in mind that they might not always
work perfectly and the next is change
the tone of your writing that is you can
ask chat GPT can you rewrite any
sentence in a more formal way so now we
will ask a prompt to charge GPT that is
can you rewrite this in a more formal
tone and what we can ask is that could
be hey how are you okay so we'll ask
this so you could see that the child GPT
has changed the tone of the sentence or
the imperative you were asking that is
hey how are you now greetings how do you
find yourself today so this is a more
formal tone and you can ask chat Deputy
for more such responses that is give me
more such responses
so you can change the tone of the
sentence that is you could give any
sentence or any imperative or any
language to chat GPT and you can ask for
any tone that could be emotional that
could be funny tone or that could be
sarcastic tone so chat Jeopardy would
reply with the particular tone so this
was a third tip and now moving on you'll
see the fourth tip that is use chat GPT
for quick learning so you can ask can
you explain the basics of anything that
could be the simple biology Concepts the
solar system and you can use charge apt
for quick learning that is for instance
you could ask any prompt
that is here we will ask chair GPD that
teach me
how to write
hello world in Python
so you can see that Jupiter responded
that is showed writing a hello world
program in Python is quite
straightforward due to python Simplicity
and here's how you can do it that is
print hello world and in this code it
has given you some sentences so you can
just read them and understand how the
code works that is print is a built-in
python function that outputs specified
information to the screen then the text
that is hello world that is an inverted
commas is a string which is a type of
data representing text then the
parenthesis that are used to include the
arguments of the function so when you
run this program it will give the output
of the text that is hello world to the
console so this is a fourth tip and
moving on now we have our fifth tip that
is view the plugin store so now chat GPT
has many plugins that is we will create
a new chat and in gbt4 you could just
click on plugins So currently no plugins
are enabled and this is the plugin store
so the developers are developing plugins
so you could use them and be more
productive and add more features to the
chat CPT so you could see that is aipdf
that is super fast interactive chats
with PDFs of any site complete with page
references for fact checking ask your
PDF chat with PDF Expedia notable link
reader so these are the plugins that you
could use
and this comes with the gpt4 version
that is the paid version
so you could enable any plugin and you
can write any prompt and the chat GPT
will respond to it now moving on to the
next step
that is tip 6 use the web browsing
feature so with gpt4 and with the beta
versions you get a feature to search
with Bing or to browse with bank that is
not available for my account or from my
area so this is the new tip you can use
it if you have the paid version and if
you are accessible for the beta version
of browsing with pink so this was our
next tip and moving on we will see our
seventh tip that is templateize useful
prompts so you can ask can you create a
10 minute full body workout using some
kind of dumbbells or a barbell roll and
save this prompt for future use you can
also templateize useful prompts for
instance you can also ask can you create
a menu or to do list and save this
prompt for future use so we'll see a
quick example that would be
creator
10 minute
full body workout and that would be
using so you could see that the chat
Jeopardy has given us a templatized
routine so as a quick high intensity
power workout that you can complete in
about 10 minutes that is bubble
deadlifts and bubble squats bubble
overhead press bubble rules verbal bench
press so for that you also need to have
bench press also and the note is
remember the key to this workout is
intensity and form not necessarily the
paid used okay so this is how you can
templateize useful prompts
and moving on the next step we have is
summarize text that is you can paste a
long article and ask chat jpt to convert
it or summarize in few sentences for
example you can paste a long arcade
article
so I will show you how we can do that we
will just search for
simply known articles
so we'll
use any article just copy it and give
this to chat Jeopardy that is paste it
and ask it can you
summarize this article
five sentences
so you know that this prompt will just
summarize the whole article in five
sentences and this is the feature of
charge epd to summarize anything and in
a very concise manner and this was our
tap eighth and moving on
the next step we have is analyze your
writing pattern
that is can you you can ask charitivity
can you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it that
is you can give it any text or chat that
you have done you can just copy that
chat and give that as a prompt to chat
GPT and you can then write a prompt that
can you analyze my writings type and
generate a paragraph by making it on any
topic so the child chapter will analyze
your writing pattern and when you mimic
your style and you can also ask it to
act as a famous person
like you can ask chargpt to act like
Elon Musk and give your thoughts on AI
so here
we will ask strategy that is
act as Elon Musk and give your thoughts
on here
so you could see that it has stated that
artificial intelligence was immense
potential for human advancement it's
eventually digital superintelligent and
can go beyond a human intelligence but
it is not saying that it can perfectly
act as Elon Musk or it can directly
speak to Elon Musk but you can provide a
perspective based on his public
statements on the topic of artificial
intelligence so the child CPT has
analyzed all its statements that are
present that is gpt4 has some browsing
features so it has analyzed all the
statements and on behalf of that it has
given us the result and now moving on to
the next step practice act as an
examiner so you can ask can you check
this essay for grammatical errors you
can ask it to check your project or even
grade your homework so as we have copy
pasted the article you can copy paste
your if you want to check your code or
debug your code you can just give way to
chat jpt and it will give you the
suggestions or it will point out some
errors and can give you a perfect code
or you can just ask him to get some
grammatical errors in your article or
essay so this was the 10th tip that is
act as an examiner and now the next is
formatted outputs so you can give any
data to chat jpt and ask him to format
this into tables and you can ask him to
add some columns to the tables that
would be Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
you can ask him to prepare a to-do list
or something like that so you can format
your outputs chargpt will respond to
that
so for that we'll just give it a prompt
to charge APD that is format the days of
week in a table and days put days in
column so let's see so you could see
that it has given us and it has given
all the days in one column so you have
to correct your prompts and rewrite your
prompts and see what chat Jeopardy is
responding with those problems so you
have to be concise and be conscious and
just regenerative problems so now moving
on to and next step
that is tip number 12 let us generate to
do list you can say I need to do grocery
shopping finish a report and call my
friend today and can you create a to-do
list for me so chat GPT can create to-do
list just tell it what task you need to
complete and it will create a to-do list
for you you can just you just have to
give it a prompt and the next step we
have is explain it to a child so this is
you can ask can you explain how a rocket
Works to a five-year-old you can ask
chat jpt to explain complex Concepts in
simple terms just say explain it to a
child followed by the concept so for
example you can also ask that can you
explain quantum physics to a child so we
will just try this prompt
that is explained quantum physics
to a child
so this will give you
so you could see that the charge Deputy
has given the answer that is absolutely
there's a very simple way to explain
point of physics to a child and it has
given a Lego books example you can build
a castle a spaceship or whole city so
this is how you can use this prompt
that was the tip number 13 that is
explain it to a child then the next step
we have is Shadow chat thread links so
after having a productive conversation
with chargeability you can share this
conversation by clicking on the share
button and sending the generated link to
your colleagues this is a great way to
collaborate with others for instance if
you are working on a project with a team
you can share the link to a chat thread
so everyone can see the conversation and
contribute so I will show you how you
can do it that is this is the share
button share a chat and you can just
copy the link and send it to anyone and
you can collaborate with them and now
moving on to a Next Step that is tip
number 15 that is export data to mail if
you want to export a chat you can click
on the export button and enter your
email address you will receive a copy of
the chat in your inbox this useful
feature is used if you want to save a
record of your conversation or if you
need to share the information with
someone who doesn't have access to
charitivity so I will show you how you
can do it so simply you have to go here
click on settings and go to data
controls and here is your option that is
export data so just click on export
confirm export and the successfully
exported data you should receive an
email shortly with your data
and now moving on we will see another
tip that is
organize your chat history
so you can organize your chat history
that is you can edit it and you can name
anything that is
tips for share jpd so this is how you
can organize your
chat history
and now moving on
now we'll see the next step that is go
minimalist
so what do you understand where
minimalist is you can just
close this sidebar so this is the
minimalist options here you can just use
the chat GPT here so in settings you can
choose a minimalist theme which will
remove any unnecessary elements from
your dashboard leaving only with the
essentials and if you prefer cleaner
look you can go minimalist and this
removes any unnecessary elements and you
can delete all your history that is in
settings you can find the delete all
history button clicking this will erase
all your previous chats and for privacy
reasons you might want to delete your
chat history you can do this by going to
settings and selecting delete old
history so this was a tip number 18 that
is delete all your history
so we'll just go to settings data
controls and here we have chat history
and training that is turned on if you
will turn off it will just turn off and
it will also act as an incognito mode
and here you can clear all the chats
this will delete all the history
and the next step we have is describe
images and the Nexus summarize YouTube
videos
so this is available with beta features
of Bing that is you can just write
describe image
and paste any image link here so the
child GPT will describe the image for
you and if you want to like know about
any YouTube video so you can just write
described YouTube video and then paste
the link and it will describe the
YouTube video for you and that is
available with the beta feature of
browsing with Bing and if that is
available with you
and currently that is not available with
me you can like if you if the feature is
available with you that is a beta
feature you would able to see here that
was the beta feature and you can also go
into settings and beta and check out if
the feature is available for you or not
and moving on
now we'll start with a chat jbt to
automate our Excel and we have some
Excel files I will upload them
in the link with the GitHub so you can
freely download them and you can also
try this project with those files and
here we are with the chat jpt so now we
are on the chat GPT website and here you
can see
that they said price at GPD option and
when you click it we will be redacting
to the chat GPT the chat box and before
that I will show you the home page
it's showing us the samples what we can
do with the chat GPT
the methods
and there's the collect demonstration
data and train a supervised policy like
how it's trained how open AI has trained
the chat GPT and its limitations
they have mentioned all the things here
iterative deployment
and moving on now we will login
to our chat jpd
I will log in with my Google account
tell us about you and this is my name
and he's asking
my phone number
so I will get this blood so you guys
won't be seeing my phone number okay
he's asking for the code
I'm waiting for the code after entering
the OTP you would be directed to this
page that is chatgpt and this is the
feed box where you can write any query
in the simple natural language that
would be English and the chat jbt would
answer your questions
and if we talk about chat jpt uh little
bit information about judgivity that
it's an AI powered chatbot that has been
developed by open Ai and the chatbot
understands natural language and
response in a human-like manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model
and the chatbot was unveiled as a
prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat GPT which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialog format makes it possible for chat
GPD to answer follow questions admit its
mistake challenge incorrect premises and
reject inappropriate requests so now we
will talk about the chat jbt so chat jbt
is an AI powered chat board that has
been developed by the artificial
intelligence and it's been researched by
the company open Ai and the chatbot
understands natural language and
responds in a human-like manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model the chatbot was unveiled as a
prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chatgpd which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialog format makes it possible for
chatgpt to answer follow-up questions
admit its mistake challenge incorrect
premises and reject inappropriate
requests
so this is jgpd and it's been boing all
the developers around the globe
so now we'll start with automating Excel
with the help of chat jbt and with the
help of Python language
so first
we will create a folder and see the
Excel files with which
we will use Python and with the help of
chatgpt
we will automate them
so first we'll create a folder for our
project and we will create in Python
projects and name it as
automate Excel using
chatgpt
and inside this
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open any idea link so that
we will write a request to chat GPT and
he'll answer us with the suitable code
and that code will copy paste into our
idle and run it if it gives any error we
will copy paste the error same to the
chat jpt and as I know he answers them
so here
we will open our ideally and for that we
are writing a command that is code space
period and that will open our ideally
that is Visual Studio mode
now
we have opener ideally and first we'll
create a file here
or first we will see our Excel files on
which we will
do the automation
and for that we'll get back to our
folder
and here we have the number folder in
which we have two files that is CSV
files
phone number and phone number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the data of the sales of
the Year 2022
so we'll use these files
sales and the number so we'll cut them
and
get to a folder
and inside the number file no we'll
start with sales
first we'll do the automation
with the sales files
so we'll open the sales folder
and inside that we will create a file
that would be the py file
and the first automation we would be
doing is concatenating all the files in
a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we will concatenate them
and ask the chat GPT to write the code
sorry to concatenate all these
so for that
we'll name the file as concatenate only
Nate
underscore data Dot py
so now
we will give the command to the chat GPT
so here is a child repeating and here
we will write a command for it
that would be I have 12 Excel files
and I want to concatenate them
and we'll also mention the name named
January
is this only
but we'll check with the final January
and then we have February
and moving on
so on we have till December
so we have all these 12 files and now we
will command him
to use python
to concatenate the data inside the 12
axis files into one file
so this is our Command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter
okay it shows us that an error occur if
the issue is
so for this thing we will just copy the
open a link and paste it here and open
it
as the chat jpd is seeing a huge traffic
sometimes it shows
these errors
so he's very famous whether we are a
robot or not
so
we will agree with the chargibility
and answer its questions here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the charge ability and we'll paste
our Command here and press enter
and here you can see that it has started
answering our question that you can use
the pandas library in Python to read in
the data from each of the Excel files
and use the concat function to combine
the data for mobiles into one data frame
here's an example of how you want to use
okay
is going you know very right menu
and he has imported panels and then
create a data frame and using the for
Loop
is going through all the months
reading the Excel file
and appending okay done
and result he has concatenating but he
has not created the
Excel file where we can see all the data
and he is also not printed it so what we
want so first we'll see
what does this code do as I have seen so
it will concatenate but it has not
created the Excel file in which we can
see all the data
so we have copied the code
we will paste it here
save it and run it
and most important thing you have to
import the pandas Library
and if you have not installed it please
install it in the command prompt with
the command pip install pandas or you
can use it in the terminal
okay
it has not found
the january.xls
okay so j n u a r y
again it's spelling we will see
what error it expects
I will save this and run once again
so we'll just copy the error and write
it back to chat GPT and see
how does it respond
okay is seeing is indicating that the
panel server is unable to find the Excel
file you are trying to read in based on
the error message look like the files
are not located in the same directory as
the python script
okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the library
in the same
folder
yeah
and we'll check once again here
let's put data.py yeah
they are in the same folder and why we
have this error
okay into
so there it is we have opened our
ideally
in
the automated Excel using chat GPD
folder and currently we are in sales
folder
so it is not recognizing
the directory
so what we'll do
we'll copy all these files
copy the sales files
and paste it here
now
now we will run the port that
chat Jeopardy provided us
okay uh yeah it has run successfully
it is good successfully okay we'll try
once again we'll kill the terminal
save it and run it again
now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
note
converted it into
a single Excel file for that we will
write
you forgot
to
[Music]
create
the concatenated
file
as we also haven't mentioned in our
Command
specifically
so we have to be specific with our
commands also
let's see
yeah after creating the data frame
to export to a Excel file and we can
just write this command
and index equal to false here okay and
he's giving all the explanations so you
can just read them correct I apologize
for the oversight create a new Excel
file light contains a concrete data you
can use the to underscore Excel method
of the data frame here is an example of
how you could do this okay you create a
new Excel file name underscore data.xl
SX the same directory as your python
script and it will contain the
concatenated data form
from all of the original Excel file you
could also use a to underscore CSM
method to save the data frame in CSV
format yeah
we can do that also
okay well
make the xlsx file
and just beneath it
okay uh
yeah
C part two uh
okay
we don't need any path we will just do
it here only
here result.2 Excel
data dot SLS
so we'll save this and run it
is showing that it has executed
successfully
and yeah outside the sales folder we'll
close it you can see that it has created
the concatenated underscore data.xlsx
so for that we move area it has created
it here
will open it
and first I will show you
what these files contain
so every file have the entry of around
thousand
every file has 1000
entries
so the concatenated file should have
around 12000.
so this is the concentrated underscore
data
and if we go beneath
yeah we can see
and it's to the guy it says it has
concatenated all the data
so yeah chat GPT responded and we have
to precise with the commands what we are
writing in English
as it has not mentioned to convert it
into Excel file now when we have written
it again it has done that so
now moving on we will do the second
automation
and for that we'll move back to our
ideally and the next automation we would
be doing would be
that we will be
using the sum and the average function
to all the files that is from January to
December files and will
use sum and average function I will show
you we will use
so it's going to get related data
so we'll open the August file
and here
you can see the
quantity in the edge column
so we'll average down the quantity
so what is the average per customer
and
in the J column we have the total cost
so we'll add all the cost in all the
files
this is the August file from January to
December we will do in color match
the average for the quantities and
column J will do the sum of the total
amount per customer
and we'll get it printed at the last
column
that would be we have the Thousand
entries
it's going till
h1001 so we would get it printed on
h1002 and the sum would get it printed
on j1002
okay so moving on we'll close these
files
we will get back to our chat GPD and
give him a command that
I have 12 Excel files
and we'll tell him that we have named
them
January
then we have
February
then
we have till December
and now
we want you to use python
to
apply
the sum formula
the sum formula and the average formula
so the sum formula would be applied from
J2 to j1001
let's see okay we have closed file you
have a random number
some formula
ROM
J2 to j1001
okay and
the average function
and now we want him to use the average
formula
from H2 to h1001
okay and that would be in all the Excel
files
and we want him to write the results
in the cells and that would be J one
double zero two
and
h1002 is respectively
so we have to be precise with the
commands and we have
an error here and that is done and yeah
it's all done
now just
give this command to charge apt and see
how it answers use dependence library in
Python to renew okay
and perform the sum and average
calculations good and then write the
results back to the same file here is an
example of how you could do this
yeah we are writing in the same file
okay we are importing Finance is PD and
running a loop for all the months we
have red
all the Excel files one by one and
we are taking the cell
um
location okay and doing the sum
and doing the mean
of the H column yeah it's good
except
yeah
I think it would
do a job
so we'll copy this and create a new file
and name it as
sum Dot py
and inside this we will paste the code
that our GPT has provided us
and we'll run this
and it has executed successfully okay no
uh we got an error that is
it has made the mistake
and rooted
okay
let me just see what query
so we don't I have 12xl files named
January 2 this I'm gonna use Python to
apply the sum formula from J2 to
j1001 and the average formula from H2 to
h1001 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done
uh we would be a little specific
let's send
j102
and okay
okay okay yeah
I mean once again submit it if we didn't
get
okay yeah now he has used open
or Excel Library that's good
yeah
that would be working first
let's see
what he will provide to us
yeah
and
okay
change
yeah
I think
uh you can serve the purpose but first
we'll run it
so he is
giving us the explanation for what he
has written this code that is this code
will apply the sum formula to the range
J2 to j1001 and the average formula to
the range H22 h1001 in all the Excel
files the results will be written in
j1002 and h1002 respectively it is
important to note that this code will
overwrite the original file so that it's
recommended to make a backup okay we
don't need that
and we have backup in the sales folder
also so you can also the read underscore
excellent underscore Excel function from
pattern
okay
so we'll try this code
it is not
trying to import OS and guys uh you have
to install all these libraries open pyxl
I have already installed them you can
search on the browser that open pyxl
installation Python and it would be
directed to pypi.com that's the official
website for the particular libraries and
there you can see the command that will
be the PIP install and the particular
command for the module name
it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see
if it has done its job or not
and in the April file we have in the H
column that is the average of the edge
column that pulls the items and in the J
column we have the total sum of the
amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully chat GPT
has provided us with the perfect code
hats off to the Jet gbt and moving on
now we'll do some other automations
and now
what we can do
uh
we have other files that is phone number
and phone number two
and what it contains
it contains the phone numbers
so what we could do is
we could add the plus 91 extension that
is the country code for India
to add the country code plus 91 to both
the files
so I'll close these files
and first
we'll copy them and paste in our
root directory so we don't get any error
and we'll
change the slide
name
instead of hyphen
we will add the underscore
okay
now we'll move back to charge APD and
write a command
and these files are CSV files node xlsx
file
yeah these are CSV files both the files
are cable files other files are xlsx
files
okay so for that we'll write the command
to charge jvd that
I have two files
uh
with DOT CSV extension
and they are named
phone underscore
number and the second was named
phone underscore number underscore two
okay so we have told the jet GPT that we
have two files and now we will tell him
to use python
to add the country code
and the
country
code
plus nine one
as
string prefix
and that would be adding as a string
prefix else it would only show nine one
it won't show plus so we'll see if chat
GPT understand that or not
as string prefix in both the CSV files
with
column name that was phone
okay now we'll just press enter
and wait for a charge upd to answer this
query
and we'll see
how it responds
you can use the printers as well okay
and the prefix to the phone numbers and
the modified data packages are okay
[Music]
about the French
it's heading as step string okay it has
understood that
and to CSV
run this code will hit in both the files
here I think this will work
we have copied the code it's controlled
in both CSV files and the plus timeline
string to the phone numbers and
write the modified data background sales
files it's modern to know that this will
overwrite the original file so it's
required to make a backup with Originals
okay
I could also use the apply function to
add the prefix to the phone number in
the column okay
okay we can do this also
with the Lambda function
and that's what
this will also do a job
first we'll see this
and we will
create a file
for this Automation and name it as
country code dot py okay
and we'll
paste the code here
and run it for you guys
but showing that it has aggregated
successfully
uh yeah it has executed successfully
so we'll just
go back to our files
and see
whether the code plus 91 as in prefix or
not
okay the numbers
okay the files code only nine one as
the column it's still in the number
format
it hasn't
converted into string format
uh we'll see the second code also
like
yeah it has converted x windows ring
okay Lambda X we'll see
whether it's working or not
it has worked uh and the issue is we
have
change the files permission denied okay
we have opened a file we'll close it
and Save
this and run it again
now it shows it has
executed successfully
we'll open the files
and now if we see
it is showing here now it has added two
nine months
you know
uh so no issues
uh the thing is first we have to
transform it into the string format and
then we can add plus nine one as a
string to that string
so chat Jeopardy misses with the
slightest
implementation the code
now moving on uh we'll see this command
later
if you want to see how we can add plus
91 I will tell you how to write that
code
okay
so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that chat jpt
improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted
the concatenated file like it hasn't
created that file it had created the
file when we have returned to it that
you forgot to create that file so chat
jpd it modulates the existing code also
and moving on
now
in any
okay we'll open the concatenated
underscore data Dot xlsx
and inside this
okay we have the product line
so what we'll do is
we will change the
name of the electronic assessors to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to Lifestyle
now we'll automate this process
and we can do this automation all the
files also from January to December
so we'll do that only okay
now here
we will command s
okay
now we'll command the chatubity that
using python
I trade
through
all the Excel files
in the
directory so we are asking him to
iterate to all the Excel files in the
directory and you will ask him to
replace
electronic assessors
electronic accessories
foreign
equipments
and
also ask him
equipments inside
okay I'll do equipment only
and
home and lifestyle we have chosen yeah
home and lifestyle
and
change it with only
lifestyle
okay so using python we are iterating
through all the Excel files and changing
these
that would be in each Excel file
so we have to be specific without
written language and now we'll save the
modified workbook in
um we'll create another folder and in
that we will save the files
okay
save the
modified
file
in the
out
put folder
and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create it
okay
then create one
hold on
add it in
okay oh I don't know why I'm saving this
so I have written the command I will
press enter
so that charge upd can process it and
give us the
code for that
so it's showing us
sweating and that was she wants you
showing us
uh you can use the OS library to all the
Excel files and directly the panel is
laminated to read in the files and make
the changes and I'm Gonna Save the
modified files okay here's an example of
how you could do this
now here
we imported OS bandages PD
and it has written the port we'll copy
that this code will iterate to all the
Excel files in the current directory
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the
sorry in the output folder doesn't exist
the script will create it
you can also use replace function to
replace values in the column okay
and they should write it through all the
cells in each row of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electron equipment and women lifestyle
with lifestyle if the cell value is
equal to the respective string okay we
have copied a code
and now we will create a file
and
name it as itrade.py
it paste the code here and run it for
you guys
the code has been executed successfully
now we'll see
open all the files not all but yeah let
me open some
that was the previous electronic
messages
okay so it hasn't changed
in this
okay we will open another file
and see if we code the changes in that
or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it hasn't
done its job
so we'll move back to GPT
and use this code if it functions else
we will write back to the chair GPD
okay
just a second
okay we are using the replace
and find an excellence
okay so for here we have to import the
OS
done
known underscore book
and for that
let me bought this
and run it
include these files
okay
now we'll see
if we quote our solution or not
no it's showing electronic accessories
and home and lifestyle
so
chat GPT doesn't
go to the code to change them
so we'll ask him another time and with a
different language this time
um
that's why I don't think it has created
the output folder
it has oh sorry
I'm really sorry what I have done is my
mistake
those were the original files
and we have the product line here
and we have electronic accessories here
and that should be equipments
okay uh we have electronic accessories
and lifestyle
let me see my command
okay I have asked them to
change Electronics with electronic
equipment and
My Lifestyle with lifestyle so let's
change only lifestyle
let's see
okay
uh the E here is small
we'll update that
in the code
you can write this back to charge apt
also but yeah
first
we'll do this
what am i showing
notice executed successfully
okay
and the output folder we have this
number
accessories
that's it the capital E okay okay
so this code is giving us error
we'll see the last code and copy that
and
try to use this
and close the terminal and run it again
it has executed successfully now we'll
see the file
and that has changed or not it has not
now we'll ask the chat GPD
what have you done brother
you're using python nitrate tools Excel
files in the duct and replace electronic
accessories with electronic equipment
and home industrial with lifestyle okay
in each Excel file save the modified
vector
okay
we will ask the same thing once again
to him
and with this electronic accessories oh
sorry
and save the modified file
the output folder and get a folder it
doesn't exist okay
okay
um
[Music]
you haven't seen once again
let's try and close these files
has executed successfully now will open
it
and now we can see that it has changed
to electronic equipment
Network equipment
yeah now it has executed successfully
maybe there would be an error
with us while coping it as we have also
created the output folder but we forgot
to see in that folder maybe that could
be the error from our site
now we are done with the
changing of the column names
uh it's the cell names that was
electronic accessories to electronic
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle
now we'll do the next automation
for that
first will open an Excel file
or this was in the output folder
you can get back to our main directory
and open the file July
inhale
here we will
filter the Excel file or gender
that is we'll select gender as female
and with the unique values in column
City
and we'll extract the data from
column A to q that would be the whole
data
and for each Unique city value we'll
create a new Excel file for each City
and that will contain data only for that
City and for females only
and after that we'll save this file in a
folder named City so we'll give this
command to chatgpt
and here you can also specify the module
you want chat jpd to use for the
particular command
here we will be commanding the chat
Deputy to use the pandas module and for
that I'm going to write the command
node command in the natural language
we'll give this command to the chat jbd
and for that we'll write using Python
and pandas
filter the
okay we will just pick a single Excel
file or we can
pick the concatenated file
that is concatenated underscore data
filter the
concatenated
underscore data
Dot
Excel SX
Excel file
and that would be or gender
female
and by the
unique values in column City
we first will give the command
by the
unique values
in the column
City
and after that we want to extract the
data from column A to q that is the
whole sheet
extract the data
from the column
A2
q and for each Unique city value
for each unique
City
value
now we will extract the data
and now we'll create a new Excel file so
for that also we'll give the command to
chat jpd
and we'll write
create a new Excel file
and that would be for each City
okay
so we'll write create a new
Excel file
or each
City
containing
data
only for
that
City
and four females
okay
and save this file in the
City folder
and if it's
not being there
GPT can create the folder for that also
okay
City folder and
naming the
each file with the city name okay
naming each file
after the
course
responding
City
okay
now
if the
City folder that is we have written a
small City
okay
if the city folder doesn't exist
then create it
before seeing the files
okay
now we have given this command to the
chat GPT and it has responded us with
you can use the pandas Library as we
have already mentioned to use that to
read in the concatenated underscore
data.xlsx file and filter the data for
gender female group the data by the
unique values in the city column and
extract the data from the specified
columns for each group and here is an
example
so we have Port the code
we'll wait till jpd continues
and we can see that the chat GPT has
completed
and
we will copy this code
for sitting you see written
City will make the director for City and
4 City Group in female data root Group
by
okay City
and you could also use the SN method to
filter the data frame for famous gender
okay first
we'll see
this
and for
that we will create filter.py
and run the code
it has been executed successfully so now
we will see that the city folder has
been created or not
I'm not able to see the city folder
okay it's been created
so let's see okay it's been created
foreign
it's still empty
so we'll give time
okay and we quote an error it is
okay okay we'll pass this error to chat
jbd first
and after that we'll see what's wrong
with this
on your so the error message you're
saying isn't getting that the column
name is specified in the list
are not present in the data frame it's
likely that the actual column names in
the data frame are different than the
ones you specified in the list
okay let me just see the list
that is concatenated data
go back
and see that is A2
okay it's still r
okay made a little mistake here
so we'll just
change our Command
here
this is it
and
instead of Q now we'll write r and save
and submit now we'll see what I do it
where it would generate for us
I'm going to close this
okay this one will influence in Excel
files we'll turn the data for a few
minutes and group the data by the unique
values in the city column great and
extract the data from the column eight
wire for each Unix ID name and then
create a new Excel file for each City
containing data only for that City and
four females files will be saved in the
city folder naming each file after the
corresponding setting okay
it's done now we'll copy this code
and paste it here and see
whether this code works for us or not
so it's being executed successfully
now we have moved to the setting okay
it's executing so we'll give time
to the code
and it do it so yeah it's been execute
successful
okay so there were three cities that was
Mandalay
and if I show you the data
you could see
that's the three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the settings only the unique cities and
it has extracted the data for the gender
female
now we'll see those files
close this
and back
in the city folder
could see them and lay City
and the data is just for the females
so this automation works well with jet
gbt
now moving on we will do one more
automation
and that would be to use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode
so for that
I will just
get you aware of the payment modes in
our sheet and we'll do this automation
on the concatenated data sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the amount of payments that is
evolet cash credit card
and these are repeating so we will use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment mode from column m
Elementary
and that is from this sheet only and
then we'll create a new sheet and name
it as
count.xlsx and write the count against
each payment method
so we'll give this command to our chat
GPT
and ask him to write the code for our
automation
so we're writing use Python to identify
use Python to identify
what is the
count
of
each
payment method
from
column and the column was n from column
n and that was it
concatenated
underscore data dot xlsx sheet
and
create a new sheet
um
named
count Dot xlsx
and
write the count
against
each payment method
okay
now we have given this command to our
chat jpd and we'll see what it offers to
us you can use the panels okay that's
the same value counts function to get
the count of each main method okay and
you can use the 2XL method to the data
frame to write the count to a new sheet
okay that's good and he has imported the
pandas library and create the
DF variable in which he has read the
concatenated file and used counts
function with payment method
and when we go okay the column name is
payment
note payment method I think it would
generate
an error for us
so
it's python of each one method from
column
and
and we will specify
column M and that is named
payment
as it has used payment method here you
can see
that it has used the
column name as payment method
so we'll specify this
we have to be very specific with our
commands
for these automations for simple tasks
you can use
simple language
no complex sentences or you have to
mention every detail but for these
automations you have to use them
now our chat Jeopardy is working with
this and mostly he will deliver us with
the perfect code I hope so
okay uh
yes right and the value gone and it has
exported
mode reset
okay
okay we'll see this
and here
we will
create a file
s count Dot py
and in this file we'll paste the code
delivered us by the chat GPT
we have
executed it
it's being executed we'll wait for that
its main execute successfully
so we have back to our folder
and we have to look for
well count final yeah count file
okay
this is okay yeah it's showing us the
mode of payment status evolit cash
credit card and the number of
usage
you know four four eight thousand three
yeah it's 12000 that was the whole entry
of the concatenated underscore data dot
xlsx so we have done with this
Automation and now we will do one last
automation
and first we'll
close all these files
okay
and moving back towards chat GPT and now
we will do
we will rename all the 12 Excel files
that was January February to December
and we will add the word
or Car Sales just before the month name
that would we will just add the prefix
before the month name
and for that
we will give the command to the chat GPT
in the natural language and here only
we'll change it in the mid directory
only as we have the copy of all these
files
so for this we'll write the command use
python
rename
all the 12 Excel files
named
January
February
until December
okay
and that is present in my directory
and what we have to do is we have to
add
the word
will add Car Sales okay
car sales
and
in front of
each
each filing
okay
so what it will do is Car Sales
underscore January Car Sales underscore
February and so on
so we'll wait for the chat GPD you can
use the OS library to iterate through
all the Excel file 7. then use the
restore training function okay to rename
the files here's an example of how you
could do this
go to S and we have the months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add cartels in front of each file name
and those files would be those only the
months
and good it's using the glow module
and you could also use the model okay
that's the second chord
extra is even okay
but we'll go with OS first
and get back to R
Aid ideally and name the file as rename
Dot py
and here we'll paste the code
and run it
it's been executed
will move back yeah you could see that
car sales have been added to all the
files
and with that we have done with our
automations and if you want you can also
submit your code to chatgpt and ask it
to add commands to your code so that it
could
explain you what that line does or what
that function does it would explain very
tediously and
if you want you can also try chat gbd to
automate many office tasks
you can automate PowerPoint for that and
do many more tasks with chat jpd on that
note if you are eager to know how chat
GPT is so so amazing what is the
intelligence behind such a tool and how
you can create one then you should
definitely look at simply learns Ai and
machine learning bootcamp acquire
Proficiency in machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning natural
language processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and more through an
intensive AIML boot Gap this
comprehensive program features live
sessions conducted by industry experts
practical Hands-On Labs industry
applicable projects and exclusive master
classes led by instructors from Caltech
so grab the course now find the course
Link in the description box during our
childhood we have heard the fictional
stories of robots taking over various
household courses making the lives of
humans easy peasy but if you are not
aware then these fictional stories are
turning into reality though not in the
form of physical robots but yes in the
form of computer programs and apps with
the help of artificial intelligence and
machine learning Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way chat
GPT is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a
as we discussed earlier chat jpt is the
application of artificial intelligence
and machine learning so to begin with
let's open chat gbt
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate and SEO optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog
so before that let's choose what kind of
blog we want to create I really love
traveling so let's try to create a
travel blog so for the travel blog we'll
find some good keywords
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
foreign
of the results
so let's try to get something for Japan
suggest me good keywords to create a
blog
on which bank
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are few places like
Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank first versus for search rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in
Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to uh
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh charge jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to say every number of words
like if this Blog has two thousand or
five thousand words you can just ask
chat GPT to reduce it to two thousand or
thousand words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this blog
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more key words
to increase its reach
suggest
you
more relevant
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for every blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
title helps the user to click on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
add the best
suitable
title in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
a bit then
optimized
title
foreign
optimize
blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and which
okay so it is showing the relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these factors
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me if you would
enter names
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these blog pages in your
website or if you have created any of
these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above but it is also
showing the significance of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 pieces to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this block
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuryoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image ideal for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
blog for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
to mount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
good
title and
Alt
tag
for
you image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
Fuji
Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
choose
the mound
LG image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
Mount Fuji
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us a suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of UNS and unsplash
pixels or Shutterstock to download the
image so we can really navigate to these
websites and download some of the
required image
for our blog
so we we have a completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
for your blog page
suggest me
suggest
do ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
above idea is best match for my blog
let's try to extract anyone from the
above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization
ideas
optimizations
for
Mount
Fuji video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey uh thumbnail uh image
suggestion uh and the video tag
suggestion right
just me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags for
the
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black button
a repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our block
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is uh which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
yes
you
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
top 10
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate this kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO optimized
URL for the
above block
scene so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine doming as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four shading
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a battling for from
your blog you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above
block so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that social engines are really in
love with the unique content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to uh chargeable
is not able to identify the duplicate
content however it is suggesting us some
of the tools like copyscape or sideliner
to understand if the content we are
creating for our blog is duplicate or
not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create a unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the chat GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of our
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
today in an era of mobile devices robots
and social media content creation is the
most effective inbound marketing
strategy
nearly 40 percent of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81 percent say
their company views content as a
business strategy
original and high quality content can
help your company stand out and attract
your customers and help your business
grow on that note welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we are here
with a fantastic video on chat GPT for
Content creation which will help you
create some compelling content on your
desired topics and if you haven't
subscribed already please subscribe to
our Channel simply learn and hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us but before we get started guys I have
a question for you is chargpt an
application and is it available on
Android well let us know the answer in
the comments below so let us understand
what is chat GPT here now content
creation can be of any type such as
blogs podcasts videos graphics and so on
but how do you create high quality
content with a few minutes in not be
worried when we have chat GPT now even
though there are numerous AI writing
tools for Content creation chat GPT
stands out from the crowd due to its
faster response rate ease of use
increased productivity support for
multiple languages and other benefits
now let's try to understand what exactly
chat Jupiter is and how to create
content from it
now generally charge GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally
chat GPT is capable of systematically
resolving all bugs while providing
detailed explanation for each step it
takes so in simple words charge GPT is a
tool that creates content for any query
chart GPT stands out among all the other
achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chart GPT
uses deep learning techniques to
generate human-like text which is based
on a machine learning model derived from
the large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
charge GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are a
variety of categories for writing a Blog
so let's pick one for chat GPD here
so as you can see we have navigated into
charge epd and let us now ask a simple
question about food blocking now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to charge GPT and it will answer so I'm
just writing a question here saying how
to
start a
foot
blogging career
so as you can see it is generating the
answer for us wait for it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a food block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love or food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose Anisha choose
a name and domain choose a blogging
platform create your blog create high
quality content and so on so in this way
charge repeatable automatically generate
the response for you based on the
questions that you are giving input to
it next we will see another question on
lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's give the question as how to
start
lifestyle
blogging in India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interests so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
important points whereas in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your Niche choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on chat GPT has been
helping in various Fields like customer
support virtual assistant education
content generation language translation
research and information retrieval
personal productivity entertainment and
more now talking about content creation
then chat GPT can prove a valuable tool
in idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
the power of AI has been overcoming
these days so without any further Ado
let's begin
chair GPT can assist you with content
SEO or search engine optimization in
following ways number one is keyword
research chat GPT can help you to
identify the relevant keywords and key
phrases that are commonly used in your
industry or required for your topic by
discussing your content with chat GPD
you can uncover valuable keywords to
optimize your content for search engines
so let's find some keywords to create
content on shoes we will create a blog
on shoes so let's add query to chat GPT
so here we got few suggestions we can
pick any of them if needed you can check
these keywords in any keyword research
tool to check their search volumes if
you require so let's choose this keyword
let's write a blog using chat GPT in 500
words on this keyword
the next we have is content optimization
chat GPT can provide insights on how to
optimize content for better search
engine rankings it can suggest where to
include keywords naturally within your
content recommends heading structure and
advice on appropriate keyword density so
to the above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GPT for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions chat GPT can help
you to generate compelling meta tags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat gbd to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this block
if needed we can rephrase these meta
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat gpts content length and
quality
Jack GPT can guide you on the ideal
length of your content based on the
search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positively infect on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe blog
as we have already written a 500 Words
length of block let's change it to
another one suggested by chat GPT
interlinking and site structure chat GPT
can provide suggestions on how to
structure your content and incorporate
interlinks effectively interlinking
helps search engines to navigate your
website and understand the relationship
between different pages boosting your
overall SEO so let's get few of the link
recommendations for our blogs on shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat jpt can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given blog
or block created by chat GPT is good or
not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPT to check whether its
readability is good or not while chat
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that SEO is a
complex field and requires a holistic
approach it's advisable to combine
charge GPT suggestions with best
practices industry knowledge and ongoing
SEO strategies to achieve optimal
results check Deputy is truly a
fascinating technology changing how we
interact with language it's the result
of years of research and development by
open AI who have trained the model on a
massive amount of Text data to create a
machine that can easily understand and
generate human-like text imagine you are
a digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that chargeivity uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chat GPT will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how child GPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every field be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CIA jpt and your options
are option A Allen musk and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and satyana data
option C Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
option D segma and masayoshi Sun Drop
your answer in the comment section below
but before we begin let me ask you if
you are aiming to get certified in
digital marketing and want to build
digital marketing then Unleash Your
digital marketing potential with simpler
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of chat GPT in digital
marketing its main USB is
rounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first on our agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learned digital marketing Master scores
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
[Music]
and vola it gave us a long version of
that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters V
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email newsletters
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter new query what is
Facebook
thank you
[Music]
it has given us a journal overview of
Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase it
more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
rephrased it and it is more interesting
to read it as well chatgpt can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing course
site
[Music]
thank you
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
thank you
[Music]
here we have an article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to as you optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
here we have fully SEO optimized article
with meta title and meta description
where the SEO optimized URL chat GPT can
also be used to train your customer
service chat boards but we can discuss
the process in some other video chatgpt
is well burst with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the queries right a
product marketing campaign Force
Implement digital marketing courses
well chat jbt has done it again this
campaign looks interesting and it will
be able to generate more leads for
simple lens courses chat jbd can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query as write a script
for five minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
[Music]
thank you
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
foreign
and I wrote a customer collaboration
email that looks professional plus easy
to read and understand on that note if
you are eager to know how chat Jupiter
is so so amazing what is the
intelligence behind such a tool and how
you can create one then you should
definitely look at simply learns Ai and
machine learning bootcamp acquire
Proficiency in machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning natural
language processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and more through an
intensive AIML bootcamp this
comprehensive program features live
sessions conducted by industry experts
practical Hands-On Labs industry
applicable projects and exclusive master
classes led by instructors from Caltech
so grab the course now find the course
Link in the description box now let's
open the jar GPT and check let's refresh
this I have already the open Match rgbt
you can just log in it and then you are
good to go so let's say hello and see
so and so again completely fine right
now okay so what will be due today is
we'll open our Visual Studio code I have
created one folder which is Tailwind
it's an empty folder you can just see
that so in that folder we'll add the
Tailwind so first let's ask the chat
repeat to help us install or set up the
Tailwind
so I'll write
please
set up the
Railway
let's see
okay
so asking us to install node.js first
and then it's asking us to
check the origin of that
okay
it's saying to install these
new programs JavaScript module
to add these component in the CSS file
so this is saying to add this in the CSS
file okay
so
let's check whether it is telling us
something useful or not
post class or don't prefixer
okay
now
simultaneously let's check
the payment website
how to install this
so here
it's saying to install this command
npim install the Tailwind CSS and then
in it in that project then it's saying
to configure the template part
to add this to your D1 configure.file
then it's saying to create a folder
input.gss
and then just start the process
so as of now
chat GPT has not given us the correct
answer it's correct but not up to the
mark as you can clearly see the commands
that are given on the
tailwind.css official website
uh so according to me many people think
that because of Charity the uh so many
jobs of the developers are in the risk
because child GPT can create websites
all of this stuff so I don't think so
according to me it's not that good it's
very good for the uh helping any
developer purpose
but it's not that good but let's see we
are in this together
so let's just open the video Studio code
and install our Tailwind now we'll ask
it to create so many other things so
let's see whether it can create that or
not so I have opened my terminal so many
people also comment us that how you
could open the terminal so I just used
one shortcut Control Plus tactic
to open the terminal you can also go
here
and create one terminal
okay now I'll paste the line to install
Kelvin CSS in my system
so let's wait a couple of minutes
as you can see it's installed in our
system all the packages and modules are
installed now it will tell us to init
this project so let's do that
okay
it has successfully created the
configure file now inside the content
we'll copy paste this one
as it is saying to add these line
configure your template path add the
path to all your template file in the
file okay so let's just
copy this thing
and paste in the content
now let's save it
okay
so now next step is add the Tailwind
directives to your CSS
now
what will we do here is
let's go back to visual studio code and
create a folder
inside this
that
SRC okay inside this SRC we will create
the file
Beautiful Lord Jesus
hair will face the good yes okay we
haven't completed that code all yet
so let God be
let's paste it here
so I don't think so again that this can
replace the developers because this is
not the correct we do
tell although it has given us all the
steps but
any developer can do the task in a very
short period of time it can just help
any developer but not
take the job of the developer okay
so let's move ahead and
step would be
to go back
next step two fill the process
let's copy this one and start the
Tailwind CLI build process okay
let's copy and paste it here
right
as you can see it's done in
273 milliseconds
the output.css is generated in this
test file folder right
now we just have to use this file
output.jss okay
let's see
now
let's create a
file here
and name it as index dot HTML
okay
and inside that I'll write my Boiler
code just pressing shift N1 for the
exclamation mark and then the Boiler
code is done so we can change the name
of this
and let's try it here as
side
using charging
okay
now
one main thing that I wanted to tell you
that I have installed one extension in
my system which is the live server this
extension you can download
and this is very helpful okay
let's open this one
now what we'll do is we'll link the
output.jss file in our gmail.gss
for that I'll write here link
okay
and inside this ring I will verb or you
can just write link and then click and
then right
here
style sheet
meanwhile
okay
what we'll do is we'll give the path of
the output.js for that dot dot slash
place
foreign
okay
close this link tag and let's save it
and let's just
right click and here you'll see open
with like server and you will install
the extension like server so let's open
this one
so this is working completely fine it's
showing that the title website using
gently
okay or something
I'll write here
welcome
to Simply learn
and then
let's save it and you will see it's
showing
welcome to simpler okay
now the next step would be to create
now let's open our
charge into d and
and we'll ride
create a
concept
header
using
let's just copy this one
and then
that's usually
okay
so
let's see whether it can give us a right
answer this time
it can
let's see
okay
it's giving us the code now for the
header
[Music]
okay
so it is showing us in the above code we
use Tailwind CSS classes to style the
header we set the background color to
Gray and this one is the property of
green color and then the text color
would be a white color in that name bar
inside the header we have the nav
element with the flex and justify
between okay classes to horizontal
Center the element space them out evenly
okay fine we also use PX4 and py3 to add
padding to the navigation bar cool for
the mobile menu we use the button with
the empty hidden class to hide it on
okay let's see
the code now
okay
now let's copy this HTML file let it
write everything shown here we don't
need this one so let's delete this
and let's here write header
and let's comment it down
yes okay let's
raise the code and check
whether it's
let's save it and let's go back to our
file so this is what charging created
for us it's looking very good actually
so let's inspect it
and let's see is it responsive or not so
this is completely responsive guys
okay very good
yeah
so
this is really very good okay
on Surface EO
s l20 Ultra this is what will show on
the mobiles okay now we'll go back to
the chat gbt and let's
clone this one and
stops generating and let's here write
create
a
section using
determine
CSS now let's see something went wrong
okay
let's see let's first copy this one and
refresh this
and let's see how it will create the
hero section using tell messages
so it has created this never really very
good
I didn't expect this from the activity
but it's really really looking really
good it's simple and you can add these
to another Pages just using the anchor
okay we can just give the path so I'll
show you www dot
okay
so this one is okay
so whenever I click on this one it will
redirect us to the simulant but the URL
is wrong so you can just go back to
simplylearn.com
and let's copy the
and let's go back to code
and let's head right
by URL okay save it and let's see
yeah this is how this works
let's close this one okay now let's see
what is the code
okay let's copy this code and let's see
how this is working so it is also giving
us the complete code how it's working
how this step is working and all as you
can see it's giving us the max W with 7
into 1 utility sets as Max weight for
the container
7xl which is 120 112 Ram or 1792 pixels
it's giving us all the explanation for
the gold it has written for us so let's
check it
and after the header I'll paste that
code and let's save it and see
okay
this is really really good guys
yeah I didn't expect this from chargpt
but it's looking very good
so
till if I am a developer so if I had to
write this much of code it'll take me
around
two three hours at least but with the
help of charge GPT it only created in
5-10 minutes
this is very good actually
now let's open the charge APD again and
here we'll create a
in publishing section
s
information
using
failment
let's see now
till now it's working really very good
now it is writing a code for us so as
you can see
let's see
again very good
now let's copy this one and paste it
under this
David
and let's check
so this is the information section this
has created for us
right important information location
office hours contact us and all right we
can also regenerate it for something
else okay now we it will create
something else for us
right
if you don't like something we can just
regenerate and create another one for
just
let's copy this one
now it's
telling us everything about the gold
and here after that I'll write this save
it
let's check what's this okay this is the
information section it has created for
us that this is something change data
and if you don't like this one also you
can again regenerate the response this
is really an amazing feature of Cat DVD
okay so now it's creating the third
option we can countlessly ask him to
create again and again for us
the response
let's copy this one
okay
and let's remove all of it because
it's looking very
clumsy
now let's see okay
this information section is information
section Welcome to our website this is
what it's written
okay
now let's ask him to create something
else okay
let's copy this text create informative
same and paste it using Tailwind with
image I'll
check whether it can a response to my
things if I want to create one image on
the left or right side and then the text
on the other side let's see whether it
can create it for us or not okay
create informative section using charge
empty with one image on the
save
and
text on the
left side
now let's see
where it can create that or not for us
right just in simple
command so we will check whether you can
create or add the image
okay assuming the classes but
text
okay I'm playing each class also
and it's taking the source from
an API called unsplash I have covered
this unsplashed API on my previous
videos okay okay now let's copy this and
paste it on our code let's delete this
one and
paste this one on the website
okay
so the image is quite large we can
reduce the sizes but in the starting
only I have told you I will not add
anything in the code so I'm not doing
anything in the code right so we can
change the size it's really good as I
have told him to add the image on the
right side and the text on the left side
that's doing the same for the user so
this is really very helpful for the
developer bit as I have already told you
it cannot replace the developers because
I am the developer I only knows how to
do things as I have showed you that it
has given me so many wrong answers
before that
report this one this has given me three
answers but it was not up to the mark so
I had to told him that took uh create
like this
or image on the right and I've explained
it to the HR GPT then it created this
one for us okay and whenever I'll we
refresh this page the image will get
changed this is the
unplash API how this works okay we can
change the images also
this is random just right here
coding okay
now you will see the images that will
come here okay
let's see
let's check it
that's not taking any other name
but let's not waste time on this
random is always so fine
till now it's looking really very good
okay
now the next step would be to add the
service section okay so let's charge the
video to create service section okay
foreign
now let's see
it's coming
okay
during the class for the side of the
water
tell him any word
so look how beautifully it has been
created
right
yeah
okay
let's see
it's done now let's copy the code and go
to our location
and here
will write this code and let's paste it
and let's check
okay
so it's not a line straight but we can
align it
so it's showing us that the services
that this website is providing what we
offer and this is some junk data we have
designed where marketing and all so
let's check whether it is
yeah
okay
so
what this one is doing here is it's
using only
between classes that is using
and the center Center
we rather using the scene class but
let's find out why the
image
is coming
like that
right
you can align it
you were guys want me to align this we
can align this right
okay
so
that's just a length one it's just one
line okay we can align that
so let's dig deep into this coat
okay
this image classes
same justify Center and then
choosing the flex shrink function
towards round and large
okay
check
[Music]
and let's go back to the court
strictly the size of this first
and
okay
again
we generate the new response and let's
see how the second response is looking
right
this week the couple of seconds more
okay let's see the response that it is
creating
we need a minimalist design okay I will
just observing the code and
you how it's looking
you can also change the color of the
customizable this website on our own but
it's really very good I'm really
impressed with this this really will
help developers creating websites okay
still creating
after that we'll create the about
section for the page okay
okay so again giving us that
design and all part
if I'll tell charge UT to create this
service action and this is my
requirement and all it will definitely
create that I guess now I'm just really
impressed with the code clean code it's
writing
and it's also responsive I haven't told
it to create the responsive code but
it's really really good it's a
responsive and I'll show you
and inspect I will just fill that only
whether it is responsive or not if you
will see it will just cut this card
it's just okay
yeah so this is how we'll check the
responsive I think and let's
see
see that these three
uh home about contacts are managed
and
this is the header part that we created
and then the outcome is the navbar this
is the information section
and services section is also there
so this is called responsive
okay
so we will check how it's looking on
Samsung Galaxy s20 this is how it's
looking
yeah let's move on to the code copy this
code and coming back to the code editor
let's delete this
section
okay
now let's paste it and see
it's giving us
this is what it created for us
and I guess
little less
or
it was already writing the code and it
stopped
it's fine it's not its mistake then
stopped and
regenerate the response
let's copy this again
coming back to the
chat
hurricane news
refresh rgbt again
service section let's see
it's really fast now
okay
let's observe this one first
Services what we offer
we have design here must some lines
about digital marketing and I'm thinking
there is also
one part which I cut down
not seven challenging the mistake it was
mine because I stopped generating the
response
okay
really good let's copy this text now and
paste it under
and let's change this and paste it
let's check it this time
so
this is how this one is looking now
we can decrease the size of this image
do not worry about that
this is the service our services and
some junk data here we can write this
website is providing this and that okay
service one that we provide this service
we provide this service and we provide
this service okay this is all about that
right really very good
really very good
it's really really good
okay you can change everything from it
customize it on our R means thing
let's just go back okay
this one is looking good okay now
let's ask charg to create the about page
for us so we'll write create
so I think
meanwhile it's writing the code for us I
wanted to tell you that strategy is
great from for everyone
but as I know the code how this code is
working I know what is section what is
their class and what are the function in
this grid system that's using max weight
uh it's using the Excel function I know
everything about it and if you are a
fresher or you don't know about anything
about the coding uh I think you should
first know about the language or the
framework then only ask this to charge
GPT or take help from the charity
meeting right if you don't know about
the language or the framework and you'll
just tell your duty to create this and
this for us it's easy it will create for
you but it will not
help you in your future
so according to me just
yeah
use it to learn not to
work okay
so
let's move ahead
and the path is given
okay
it was again managed oh let's ask it
again
responsive
about
section
using
table
okay I just based on but it
is very intelligent
I misspelled the Tailwind spelling and
then it corrected it
very good
so this is not the complete code for the
about page I'll ask to
and T and then it will take this command
or not
right right so let's see
after this about section we'll create
this contact page and then we'll
find this website right
so this is really really helpful for the
developers I must say
so
let's copy this and
code and paste it under this
section
okay
this is how the about page is looking
really very good now imagine size is 500
into 500 it's really really big so we
can change the size of the image
let's see
that is that
to 50
and then it will not come again
let's just delete the source
of in the unsplash
for the random image
right
that command is really useful
okay to add that
this is how like this about is looking
really very good guys really very good
if I tell a charge if you need to create
this on the right side or this image I
want on the left hand side or right hand
side it will definitely do for us as I
have given him the
uh task in this section information
section it definitely worked
so I must say it's really really good
so
now let's move on to the
contact page okay
let's here right create
a responsive
contact
section
using
feeling
and I'll ask him to do add some sections
for us so let's see whether it can take
up that or not
okay and let's view it in a second shot
let's first see how is the contact
Section is looking then we'll tell you
to improvise that
so it's just taking a section class
inside that section class it's using
some classes which is legs wrap and all
and it's giving us
it's really important
let's copy this text again and paste it
here
so the contact us is also looking very
good get in touch and then it will
redirect us to the
button really good really
the images sizes are
[Music]
large but we can reduce it it's not a
big deal but it's all looking very good
right
so one thing is left is the footer part
let's ask it to create a filter for us
now
okay this is the last and final step for
this
create
section
using
and
from income
this is really very good looking very
good let's add the
splash
and then
use it here
so this is
how
it's looking down
so overall if I see it really given us a
good good output really
so I will say child Liberty can only
help us that's it
as this code that is created by child
Liberty for us we can't use it directly
this structure that charity created for
us is good but we need to add so many
things before deploying it right if I'll
see this one we need to add this
services in the center and we need to uh
arrange the text and the services we
need to change the size of the services
if the client wants it
horizontally then we have to change that
we need to change this image size as in
front of you I changes email sizes I use
the different apis
so overall it's very good but there are
so many things that we have to do okay
and for that developers are needed as
technology advances in all aspects of
Our Lives programming has become
increasingly important it is used in
many fields and industries including
software development gaming and
entertainment education scientific
research web development and many more
so needless to say the demand for
programming and coding in the IT
industry will probably keep increasing
for the foreseeable future but where
does charity PPT open ai's popular
language model fall in this chain that's
exactly what we are focusing on in this
today's video on that note welcome to
the simply learn YouTube channel today
we are here with an interesting video on
chat Deputy for programming as I said
earlier programming is utilized in many
domains like web development robotics
mobile development machine learning and
so on so how can a program achieve
maximum code efficiency nowadays we have
EI based tools like chargeability to
make our programming experience more
efficient although there are several
coding resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charging stands
out from the competition because of its
quick response time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how Chad GPT Works chargedipity
generates responses to the text input
using a method called Transformer
architecture a large volume of text is
fed into the charge GPT from various
sources including books websites and
other social media platforms the model
then uses this information to forecast
the following word in a phrase based on
the words that came before it the charge
Deputy systems allows users to enter
text or queries and then the system uses
its training data and algorithms to
produce the right answer the answer is
created after the input text has been
examined and the pattern most likely to
match the input have been identified
using the training data in short charge
APD is designed to respond to queries
logically and command more quickly and
accurately but why do programmers use
chargeability on a regular basis
chargeability assists programmers by
offering programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills beside that charge Equity is
utilized for code generation code
completion code review and a natural
language interface let us understand
each in detail charging is trained to
generate the code or even the entire
program described in the natural
language specified by what they want a
program to do and then charge video
could generate the relevant code look at
the example of how chargpt generates the
code so now open the charge GPT and you
can type any program that you want rgbt
to generate so I will give write a
parallel to program in Java so here you
can type write a
palindrome
program in Java
so using Java programming language it
should generate the whole program
so as you can see it has generated the
program so it has used a class name
called palindrome Checker and it has
used each palindrome as a method name
and also it will give the explanation on
the program so you can see here why it
is explaining why each palindrome is
used as a method and it also explains
the for Loop if
a condition and so on next we have code
completion charging is trained to
generate Snippets of code or even fully
fledged programs it can generate a list
of possible code completion depending on
the context of the user's incomplete
piece of Code by automatically producing
the entire code it can help the
developer save time and minimize errors
next let's see the example of code
completion using tatibility so even if
the program is explained in natural
language charge Deputy will generate the
proper code and give the complete code
so let's type here
using a function
write a program
to convert
the string
in uppercase
so using which language let's keep using
C programming
and enter it once again
so as you can see we have just said that
using a function write a program to
convert the string in uppercase so using
C programming language and using C
programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
come given the complete code for string
to convert a string in uppercase and
also it gave the explanation here the
convert to uppercase function takes a
pointer to a string as its argument and
then iterates over each character in the
string using a for Loop so it explained
why for Loop is used why two upper is
used and why the method convert to
uppercase is used everything
so let's say we'll give one piece of
code like void
to Upper
care
Str
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code
so this is how charged PDF works for
code completion next code review
chargingly can analyze code identify the
box or errors in the program and further
help resolve them it allows developers
to fix errors more quickly so now let's
have a look at the example of code
review so in this example chat Deputy
will review the code so even if the code
has some mistake it will give the proper
output let's say we have given the
example here so we gave
the function or a method called upper
and here we are giving
the keyword called upper so you should
check whether this piece of code is
proper or is there any mistake in this
so as I said
it's saying that the given code appears
to have logical error as a function
upper is being called recursively on
itself inside the loop
so instead of giving two upper we just
gave upper here right so using the
keyword to Upper only then the string
can be converted to uppercase so here we
gave just upper so it says that it is
having this piece of code is having a
logical error and it gives the proper
code for us
so I hope it's clear
and then we have natural language
interface with the use of charge apt a
software application can be given a
natural language user interface that
enables users to communicate with it
through natural language instructions
rather than through conventional user
interfaces next let's see how chargity
helps the programmers for natural
language interface so let's say we'll
give your
create
a software application
where
the user
asked to enter
credential
for the to-do app
enter
so as you can see
the charge beta will give the steps so
it can provide you with an outlet for
creating a software applications that
requires the user to enter credential
for a to-door app so here it is few
steps that we need to follow to do a
to-do app
so it's giving the explanation step by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in
um you know it will have the options
like add edit and delete task as well
and then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intendent and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed
I'm sure you all are aware of charging
at this point the Revolutionary new AI
based chatbot developed by open AI have
taken the World by storm thanks to its
near lifelike responses and a very
intricate pattern of answers they have
never seen this level of expertise from
a chatbot before which really made us
think to what extent can we push it
there are many questions on lead code
that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far charge GPD can
take us hobby finally reached the stage
where AI is going to replace us let's
find out so basically here we will be
listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if chat GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
here is the lead code let's see uh in
our list which is the first question
that we are going to implement in our
chat GPD and see if it's able to solve
it or not
mainly will focus on hard category
questions only so
according to my research there's a
question of median
of two sorted arrays
so as you can see the success rate is
35.7 so let's see the charge Equity is
able to do this question so first let us
go through the question
okay
press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted arrays so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question
and this is a good but the charge GPD is
that before uh giving the code it's
actually explaining how they are putting
the logic in together in the code
so probably you can use this logic to
create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code is
quite a learning program
is in Python so if you are looking for
your Solutions on chat GPT you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in
so okay it's it's also gives that okay
that the time complexity will be o log
Min m or n so let's see if it
the case or not
so we have copied it and we quickly
paste it over here
as you can see
uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh
syntax and you can see the indentation
over here is perfect but here it's not
so I feel that something like this is
something with lead code
so let me just quickly Rectify this you
can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct program
uh now you can see here we have an error
let's see copy this and see what chart
GPD has to say for this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums 1 and nums two ask GPT if it
can write the code with self-argument
and see if it's correct
and read that if it can pass a
self-argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new code
okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three arguments
let's
copy this code
put it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process
oh no this time it's fine okay so now
quickly run this program let's see if
this time it passes all the test cases
or not
I think it doesn't needs because the
class is already mentioned over here
uh
yeah
okay the runtime is 35 Ms and as we can
see case 1 and case 2 is definitely
passed
so
let us see if
this code can pass all the test cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there is a runtime error
so
as the first question in our list chat
GPT was unable to solve let's move on to
our next question
that is zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for it
this is the question here also you can
see the success rate is definitely below
50 and the difficulty level is medium so
the Hard One charging Beauty was not
able to solve let's see if this can be
done
question so it will give a string that
will be written in a zigzag pattern on a
given number of rows
and then you have to read the line in a
certain
as you can see over here
we have to write the code that will take
a string and make this conversion given
in a number of row
has also made a certain amount of
certificate uh repeat that's also given
a certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning everything
so let's quickly copy this
okay
now that we have mentioned all the
specifications
uh let me quickly
feet
and paste it now let's see what code it
has to generate
it's implementing the code in C plus
plus so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's quickly
like the code oh it's already C plus
plus okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and Java
and it's generating an alternative code
as well for us
that's Sharp
just quickly copy this code
um
the one I think it's uh okay so it's
generating in uh
Java
let's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C plus plus one the first code
generated by it
uh is correct or not
okay copy the code
paste it over here
dilation error
okay okay
28 okay
so let's do this error
the one thing
definitely this time we have mentioned
all the constraints criteria
specifications that we wanted in a code
but again
judging
questions we have implemented till now
let's see if it has any success rate in
further
okay it seems okay
and now it is okay so this time it is uh
generating the solution or considering
the error in Java
see what it has to say in Java and we'll
make it specific that the error was in C
plus plus program so it generates the
correct code
plus plus program
what it has to say
oh those things
so this error is something related to
the compiler and now it is giving the
updated code in C plus plus
is the correct one or not
should apologizing for making arrows in
their Solutions
quite fascinating
[Music]
um
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or not
let me see if the all the braces are
covered over here or not
I think it's missing a brace
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was missing
um
for that
definitely something with the code but
okay we can give that to charge GPT it
was partially lead quotes issue because
we were copying still it was not giving
the error that there is a brace missing
has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3M is now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not mind it this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraints
so let's see if this has two into
okay so this time it has passed all the
test cases but still my conclusion with
this question is uh it was still not
able to generate the solution in one go
uh but so I can give that to charge GPT
because the first error that we faced
was more of a lead code this issue
because it was something with company
and charge gbt was able to give a proper
oh now let's go back to our problems
list
so
right now the score is one and one it
was unable to solve one question and one
not
so let's have a look at the third
question and see if that brings any
difference to the chart gpts
scoreboard right now or not
one question that we are going to deal
with is substring
with
concatenation of all words
this is in the category again and the
success success rate is 31.1 percent
which is even lesser than the first
question that we faced which was median
of the two sorted Aries
we're trying here we are actually trying
to cover all the Spectra the huge
Spectra of different types of
questions and you know categories
available in coding and to give you an
idea of how
beneficial charging can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you can say well
established companies among companies
so here this video is specifically for
you to give an idea that whether you can
use it for your benefit and you know to
get an idea or you can actually
compare it with your
subjects uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third question
is that you're given a string and an
array of strings probably words and all
the strings or words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has a b c d e f then a b c
d e f basically uh has done all the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that
there's a big party
uh
Vision that ecdbef is not a concatenated
substring because it is not the
concatenation of any permutation of
words
so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S string
also you can choose any order for it
here it has also given a
two examples for you to
understand the question in a better
perspective
now
really uh copy this question and see if
what programming language argibility
chooses to answer this time
but with no chat again
be these constraints
okay it's just a question
okay
this is the solution that we're getting
right now you requested a model that is
not compatible with this engine please
contact us through our help center at
help
dot openai.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has a
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to implement
uh your task in it so again let's
quickly
paste it over here
that we want a code the right code
return now
press enter
same definitely it's not giving the same
error
let's see it this time it charging PD
has anything to give as a solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python
the more thing every time chargeability
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for C plus
plus
and this time it straight away wind for
the code so definitely we can say that
it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches adding charge if
it is capable to capable enough to give
that
that the code is generated let's quickly
copy it
and
paste it over here
I feel the indentation issue is going to
be there
it was not there okay
F probably I think if we backspace
issue let me quickly Rectify this and
I'll
do once the indentations are
but
the indentation is projected now let's
have a look
at the Gold if it's correct or not let's
quickly run it
definitely it has given our first syntax
error again
I can see that even there's a big video
question it definitely goes to at least
one error which is mainly the syntax one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with the
charge GPT code generation
pretty good okay
all right we have given the error okay
it seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function type and
so introduced in the version we are
using is lower than that okay so
basically it's generating now in the
python version
uh probably this code is
well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that helps
in it
is actually generating the code
okay again
given the other one I think it's again
something with the self
uh
one the new code generated is here
we'll definitely come back to that error
and have a look at the Python 3 code
also
uh first let's copy this code
and
in giving the same error
and see what it has to say
uh you know every time the charge APD
generates the python code we cannot
ever takes self as an argument but
believe that
as you can see when we start the code
it's already mentioned what arguments we
need to pass from
a particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code so
that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct and
the one goal so probably I'll get this
point to GPT it's something with the
lead code because it's passing that
parameter and everything we have to
mention that parameter pretty much when
we do the chargeability is able to solve
the question so let's see let me
actually mention that
because self parameter self argument
from that parameters I'm gonna make it
one of the parameters
processing that
yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code and you know
item three
but we can give that to charge GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument
so once we mentioned that error and when
we mentioned that specification that if
charging can pass self argument through
that particular function in that code
the solution is pretty much
right so here it's also implementing and
giving the answer
okay it also has mentioned that it's
important to mention import important
list and counter so
okay
just copy this because again there will
be a lot of uh invitation issues
okay now that we have it
copy the code
I was already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the function
paste it
let's run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or not
yeah there's an indentation issue
let me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28 MS
now let us submit this question and see
if it is able to pass other test cases
or not
accepted
so it is able to pass all the test cases
and I think this is something with lead
code again uh whenever we are generating
the python code we are actually passing
self argument uh in lead code but charge
GPD is not assuming it so this solution
is definitely correct
even though we are specifying everything
we will have to be more specific that we
have to run one more argument uh from
the function so that it you know
generates the solution in one go so let
us try that in our next question
but we can definitely see charge APD was
able to solve this so now the scoreboard
is two one one uh among three questions
it is definitely able to solve two
questions even the first question it was
able to generate a correct solution but
it was not that accurate to pass all the
test cases
to a question list
the next question that we are going to
cover is in Queens
category but still the success rate is
63 over here again a new genre or
question we are covering over here let
us see it
solve it or not definitely the success
rate shows that many people were able to
do it definitely more than half of
people who have attempted it so see if
the question can
this AI can beat that or not
so I have to copy this question this
question mentions that the end Queens
puzzle is the problem of placing n
Queens on an N into N Chess board such
that no two queens attack each other
given an integer n written all listing
solutions to the end Queen puzzle
so basically n is any given number and
you have to create a puzzle of end n and
you have to arrange all the Queens in
such uh you know way also the number of
Queens in the board will be equal to the
number
in and in such a way that it is not able
to attack each other in any case
puppet this part of the question
and the constraint is
just one let me
that it will be easy to keep a track of
what all questions charge GB is able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in interviews uh whenever you actually
go to technical rounds and for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular uh they are considered
as very uh suitable questions to check
to check your you know IQ and to check
your potential like how well aware you
are towards your coding potential
now we have pressed enter it is giving
the logic it is going to implement in
its code one approach to solve the end
Queens puzzle is to use backtracking
I guess to start by placing a queen in
the First Column of the first row so
let's see if the codes
again capable to you know
solve it or not
again it's giving the python code
generating the code let us quickly see
whether it's python or Python 3
written python 3.
okay
once the code is generated I'll also
write that you need to pass one more
argument from the main function
uh that is self and let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or not
should what I want and delete this C
sure here's an example of how you can
pass an additional parameter self let's
see if it suits
the code or not
from the 12 and queen function is a
method of the end Queens class and it
takes self as its first parameter
followed by the integer n so yes this
solution does take self as a parameter
so let's see if this can
run in one go or not because this time
we've already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is
syntax error of not mentioning parameter
self
actually
let me see the indentation if it's
correct or not
this time uh let us quickly run this
class
okay there you go now you can see that
it has actually run the code in one go
and all the test cases are passed in one
go even the runtime is 39 Ms so
definitely charge gbt is able to provide
the solutions the Logics in a proper
manner it's just that we have to be more
specific with what we want exactly uh
from chat GPT right now we can see that
it has been able to successfully
generate 4 out of five uh questions that
we have actually implemented till now
out of which four are from hard category
let us submit this code and see if it
also covers all the test cases
internally fed in for this question just
a second I think I will have to submit
it again
thank you cool it has accepted all the
test cases and this question is done by
child GPT it has actually implemented
this question that we are going to cover
till now I can say charge gbd has taken
the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge success
but um I can still give that to charge
upd as it is in Ai and still in a you
know developing mode but still if it can
give you 90 of the output correct it is
a pretty decent and you know amazing
thing to do
question is shortest sabare with some at
least K now let me search
for it
again this question is from hard
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see if this
question can be solved by chart GPT
let's have a look at the question given
an integer ad in nums and an integer K
return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with a sum of at
least K so if there is no such sub array
return minus 1.
so
the body is a contagious part of an
array it has also given a description of
what an array is or what sub array is
so now that we have
written a new chat
and let me
explains
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a code
so I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the code
specific
so yes it's giving an implementation of
the algorithm in Python
uh again we can see it's not the Python
3 it's python uh little no version of
python
um
50.
let's do
python
then we have to pass self
so it has generated code and explain
what all variables and what will
statements have the individual
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adheres to it and
generates new code with self parameter
okay so here
is the new code which passed through the
main function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
till now that it was able to generate
logical and you know
pretty much decent solutions for every
question
the spouse to the class as an argument
when an object is created and is stored
as an instance variable the shortest
subari takes K as an argument which is
the target sum so basically it's trying
to explain the code that what exactly
it's doing and what individual
statements have as an influence on the
code
and whatever parameters they are passing
what influence or what position they
hold in the code
so definitely charge APD is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it
and when it's generating the code as you
can see here we have legit explain the
whole code how it's actually functioning
that's a good way to you know put
emphasis on you know put a confidence on
the solution
remove this
I better okay
okay so it's apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or appearing to the syntax error or type
error generated
right or not
you mentioned that here direct method
takes two arguments one for the nums
array and one for the K which was the
error exactly
and it's again explaining the whole code
so that one person who watches code or
you know logic could understand the
functionality of it
let's say this code can run
food
checking for indentation removing class
and run
it's one more type error
let's copy it and
and we mentioned that we want
self-argument to be passed
it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice
so let's see this time it can work out
issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion seems that I
misunderstood
that you are trying to call the function
directly without creating an instance of
the class and that
function outside of the class and simply
Call It by passing the parameters like
this okay the code is definitely
generated by itself so definitely I am
not calling any function uh
the code I copied was actually generated
by charging itself so it's contradicting
its own pointers Maybe
right we have copied the question uh
sorry the code
let's paste it
again look for indentation
and run this code
okay once again it is not able to you
know
us
I am error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste it
again according to chat GPD it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anyway
generated by charging PPT so yeah
this time I think GPT is trying to
contradict its own logics
let's see if the current code can do the
miracle of solving this question
last
and run
okay so after four attempts of running
the codes generated by charge GPT on
delete code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so
I can I have a very contradicting point
right now uh
not exactly contradicting more of a
skepticism that okay Chad Jeopardy does
generate a proper code or logic but it
doesn't considers all the criterias or
it also has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong context
so I feel that when we as a human try to
solve these questions we definitely try
to implement all the Logics and if we
get it we can actually get the code in
one go
magic or you know demand of the question
and be AI being Superior version or you
know trying to be the superior version
of human brain and going to the extents
of a human brain
still faces those issues
can be uh you know drawback for chat GPT
because you can see for this specific
question we have face multiple types of
error and we have seen charge a pretty
contradicting its own prior code
so
definitely this is something to consider
or you know something to think about
submit this code
and after like I said after getting four
attempts it is still not able to pass
all the test cases it is only able to
six pass 61 out of 97 test cases
which is almost 70 percent of the test
cases 30k percent of this test cases are
still not passed even though we
mentioned all the constraints we have
mentioned the comments we have mentioned
all the errors that but this particular
code can go through
still it was not able to generate the
proper code that could go through all
the test cases
so
this was a fail for chart GPT uh at
least till now we have made out this
point that charge GPT is definitely not
able to solve every question
array with same average
for it
array with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success read is only
25 percent
Let me refresh it and remove this code
now let's have a look at the code what
it demands so you are given an integer
had a nums now you should move each
element of nums into one of the two
arrays e and B
and B are non-empty and the average of
array a is equal to average of array B
or return true if it is possible to
achieve that
condition is not justified
so given a note that for an array uh
average array is the sum of all the
elements of array over the length of
array okay so it is giving you the lot
of how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly
and also it has given a few examples to
give you how the code needs to be
projected or implemented
please copy the code and paste it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
however this approach would have a Time
complexity so it's also giving that this
approach can have a Time complexity of O
to the power n so again it's suggesting
a different approach a more efficient
approach that will be using dynamic
programming now that can be used to find
the subsets with a specific average and
create a 2d array with the length of I
and J which that will be the length of
the two
we have actually given as input and
represents whether or not it is possible
to get a sum of J using the first
moments of the nums array
so
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o and S so definite it is not
given a code let me ask for it
not for every question chart GP is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them
as you can see I've mentioned this time
to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
also mentioning comments that what every
snippet of the code is actually for and
what it will do like here you can see it
will fill the 2D r2dp uh DP stands for
dynamic programming this here it has
mentioned initialized the First Column
as true so it is also mentioning the
comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better way
it's also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums
array is non-empty and that the elements
of the numzare are non-negative integers
okay also the above implementation will
return the possible subset that can be
formed by the array to fulfill the given
condition and not pulling true and false
but that's what we want exactly right
uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and
see this code can run or not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass self
uh
parameter
or indentation
and
foreign
specifically
uh
sure here is an example of how you can
pass the self parameter so now the
current solution will pass self
okay
great there was an error okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the
criteria I just mentioned that I need
self parameter to be passed through the
function can partnership
so I have copied it and let's quickly
paste it over here
uh you know pass
all the cases are not wait uh we need to
remove this
okay it's done now quickly just run this
program
okay so here is uh
error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what Char
GPT has to say about this error
okay the error message solution object
has no attribute
uh split array same average suggests
that there is no method named with this
in the solution class so it is likely
that the test case is trying to call
this method but it does not exist in
your implementation anyway that I have
not mentioned this method this was given
by chargeable itself so again we can see
the condition that it is contradicting
its own so again it has generated new
response and it says that it should
resolve the issue and the test case
should be able to call this particular
method correctly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see that
now is it able to run or not and pass
all these test cases or not
and click on run
okay now the new generated response it
does works for this particular question
and the runtime is 12 Ms and it does
passes the first two cases mentioned so
let us quickly submit this code and see
the code is perfectly you know fine to
deal with all the test cases actually
fed by lead code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60 percent of uh total amount of
test cases
so let's move on to the next question
that is find substring with given hash
value so let me quickly search for this
question
find
substring
with
cash value again it's
it's a question from hard category and
the success rate is
22.2 percent so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given integers B and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters SPM
uh this is the logic given how we want
our output to be demonstrated in certain
value or how the hash can be generated
the particular formula uh how you can
get the hash value of your you know
string
so the question is you are given a
string and then teachers
and you have to return the first
substring of that string of length uh
given to you here it's K the test cases
will be generated such that and answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
charging consoles so that it gets
all the specifications
with the code and
so I have copied the code and I'll paste
it over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my class
and
my dad faces a type error so let's move
on to the next question again we saw
that Chachi but he was not able to solve
this particular question coming back to
our list the next question in the list
that we are going to cover is partition
array into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question
I want to shouldn't add a
to
two arrays
again this question is from hard
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition array into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
or we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly we'll copy
this question and see if it is able to
solve this question or not first we have
to create a new chat
I'll be
all the constraints
let's see what charging pity has to say
for this particular question
let's
ask it to generate a code this time it
has only generated a logic not exactly
Logic the approach indeed they are going
to follow or anyone can follow to solve
this question
let me ask if it can generate a code
okay it's definitely taking longer time
to generate this code
okay here is the code which is possible
python implementation and
[Music]
okay the code is generated and it's
mentioning that the code takes in an
input an array of integer called nums so
basically uh it's explaining that what
it actually is doing which is pretty
much explained in the question itself
that what exactly it needs to function
like and what will be the variables and
what will be the inputs and how it needs
to be segregated to uh obtain our
Optimum result
so
let's copy this
and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know uh
again we could see that
past self parameter
okay
and then
attribute error let's quickly copy it
paste it over here
see what chart GPT has to say about it
okay
that you have seen that after placing
the error it's giving that error message
you're seeing suggests that there's a
problem with the function name in your
code so the error message is indicating
that there is no function called minimum
difference within the solution uh also I
have seen that apart from the function
name it doesn't have a self parameter so
let me just write it down
elf
argument
apps let me copy it that will be better
and write the
new code with it
let me see if it can generate a new code
this time
so yeah it has agreed so there is an
example and here's the code
I have copied this
and
paste it over
here
be any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code
but yeah we can definitely think of
running now
let's run this code
we copy it and paste it over here again
an error has prompted out I
don't know how valid
code will get after projecting this
error over here in charge GPD
so yeah definitely considering the error
message you are seeing is indicated that
the function is returning INF which is
not a valid value for the expected
return type integer
so in the base case where I and J are
both 0 the value of is set to float
which is positively Infinity however the
expected output is an integer so this
valid this value is not valid so again
considering this change the
chargeability is giving a new code so
let us see how valid this new code is
okay I can see that it has changed the
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed but it has uh written a new
syntax a new logic over there
let's see how accurate charge GPT here
is
now okay we have pasted logic
uh yeah as
oh okay sorry I need to remove these two
lines
now let's quickly run this program
okay so now as you can see it could only
pass one test case
but not the first two so there's no
point of submitting this code as you can
see that the logic for the score or this
code and as a whole is not
well moving on
next in the list we have is
longest common subpar now let's see
longest
common
so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27 now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you
cannot just miss out on any
specifications
talking about the constraints called B
and paste
now enter
giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't want any code
over here so let's try
that if it can present a code
because I have asked to write a code for
this and yes charge GPT has definitely
agreed to provide me a code for it uh
charging is done with its explanations
I'll type it out and wait for the new
code which will contain self as a
parameter that it's the score is pretty
similar to the previous one it's just
that it's using the self argument the
function as it was mentioned by me
so let's quickly copy this code
paste it over here
check for the indentation
we run this code
I should again
okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charging
body has to say about this
okay the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounds checked before being used to
access elements in the path and TP
arrays okay so we have found a new code
let's quickly copy this code and see if
this code is capable of you know
eliminating the errors we
probably found
click copy and paste
let me check correlation
done and run
then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet charging is not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list
that is going to be uh sum of total
strength of wizards hopefully this
question does from married for child GPT
and prove itself lucky the charity graph
for this video because for now we can
see it's a 50 50 scene uh half of the
question chargingly was able to provide
Solutions with and have other questions
charging Beauty couldn't actually figure
out what
needs to be done even the logic and
approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct
so let me search for this
question some of total
strength of wizards again a hard
category question so let's have a look
at the question first
let's click copy this question
uh create a new chat
paste it over here
and
look for constraints now that we have
copied it
paste it and enter
he is giving an approach how you can
actually think of a solution for this
particular question charge ability has
not generated any code
uh let me ask for it
okay
so here's an example again they have
implemented the code in Python now it is
also giving a note that the approach is
valid only if you're allowed to modify
the original array and also we are not
working on down over
function and then write this
code so let's see if we can do it with
self argument
okay so yeah there's an example it's
generating the code
okay so let's see
what's the update with the code
here
this
episode are
let's add
solution
and run the code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why
okay
this error
and paste it over here
you have to say
the error message solution object has no
attribute mode suggest that there is a
class name solution and the code is
trying to access an attribute named mod
on an instance of that class with
attribute doesn't exist we probably need
to make more specifications and if it
still doesn't works then it clearly
classifies that charge dpd doesn't takes
every point or a classification uh you
know in consideration which ultimately
uh
you know reflects on the solution
the new code is here let me quickly
paste it
okay
let's try running this code let's see if
this works
try running it again
it has a runtime error was unable to
solve one more question now that we have
tried and tested a huge spectrum of
questions from Lead Core on charge GPT
we can conclude that though charge GPD
is an amazing tool with the bright
future it's has its own limitations and
maybe it is not ready to replace humans
or compete with human brains these
questions were picked from a list of
frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chat GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
that shows that a proper solution to
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts Chad Jeopardy
was not able to find the correct answer
but we can also give charging the
benefit of doubt that it's still it's in
its initial phase and still there are a
lot of aspects that need to be worked on
so probably in future charge GPT can
take an upper hand over this but for now
charging needs to do a lot of work for
these situations on that note if you are
eager to know how chat GPT is so so
amazing what is the intelligence behind
such a tool and how you can create one
then you should definitely look at
simply lens Ai and machine learning
bootcamp acquire Proficiency in machine
learning deep learning reinforcement
learning natural language processing
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and more through an intensive eiml
boot camp this comprehensive program
features live sessions conducted by
industry experts practical Hands-On Labs
industry applicable projects and
exclusive master classes led by
instructors from Caltech so grab the
course now find the course Link in the
description box
and moving on we will start with our
project
and for that first we'll create a folder
in Python projects
and name it as
Telegram
Port using chat jbd
okay and inside this will open the
command prompt
and open our
ID that is I would be using the video
Studio code and you can use any ID that
you have Hands-On
and now
we will go back to our chat GPT
and we'll start here but before that
let's talk about telegram board so a
telegram Port is a program that
interacts with users via the telegram
messaging app
uh the plate requisite is you should
have a telegram account and Boards can
be used for a wide range of purposes
such as customer support news delivery
and even games
and chat Jeopardy so chat Jeopardy is a
large language model trained by open AI
that is based on gbd 3.5 architecture
and cheer activity is capable of
generating human-like response to text
based inputs making it a great tool for
building chat boards
and now if we talk about prerequisites
you should have a telegram account
python installed on your system and we
need a python telegram board library
that I will show you what to install and
that charge gbd will tell us equal to
install
so we'll just ask chat Jeopardy
to create
telegram board
using
python
okay so it says error we'll just refresh
the page
and ask again create telegram board
using python okay
I will see what
these states so greater telegram board
you need a telegram
mode token to the board father yeah we
have to go to the bot folder I will show
you guys how to do that
control the required libraries next we
need to install
okay and write this code
okay
so in this script
they have started with the start
function so
it will just says hello
when it will be started
okay
so we will add some more functionalities
and
we will ask where to find the
your API token here so I know like we
have to go to the
code further but we will ask charity
video also
we can we find
the
repeat open
so it states that to get to telegram
about API token you need to create a new
bot by talking to the bot further on
Telegram
open telegram and search for board
father okay and send the board further
message that is Slash new mode and the
board father will ask you for the name
of the board and
it will ask you about the username and
fifth is the word father will then
generate a token for your board this
token is a string of characters that
uniquely identifies your board on
Telegram
so keep this token secure and I will
also blur it so you guys won't be able
to see it okay
so moving to a telegram
we'll just search board further here
and you can see this is the board father
and we'll just click on start
and they asked the chargedy asked us to
write Slash new mode we'll just click on
this and we'll get
so we'll write a new board how are we
going to call it please choose a name
for the board
so right
simply learn
underscore new
bot okay
good let's choose an username
so simply
learn
one one underscore port
and it states that that your username
should end in both
so we have landed with board
and you could see the token here and
here you can just access your board
so
we'll get back to our ID
and create a new file and I will name it
as new DOT py only
or you can name it as board.viewer
anything you want
we'll get back to our
charge GPD but before that first we need
to install the library
for that you can go to the command
prompt or you could use the terminal of
your ID
that is
in Visual Studio code you could you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied as this
library is already installed on the
system
so moving back library is installed and
now we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and we'll just change the token
we'll go back to board further
we'll copy this token
come back
and paste it here
okay
now we will
run this and see whether our border is
working or not
so it has successfully executed
I will get back to our portfather and
just
click on simply run one board
so
if we click on start
and see it says hello I am your board so
it's working fine
so if we write hello
it won't respond as there are no
functionalities so we will ask chat
deputy to add functionalities
please
and
some more
functionality piece
and this once
to the port
let's see
so sure here's an example of how you can
add some more reality
so they used what up data and dispatcher
okay
let me Define the help command Handler
so
chat GPT has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does equal to it
will just give you the same thing but
you give to the bottle but you write to
the board caps
that
he has also declared a help function and
in which you can see like what
functionalities does the board have and
the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps Eco Echo the message
back to you it will give you the same
message
slash start it will start the port and
slash help to get help
and now
unknown uh if there is something you ask
out of these things it will just say
sorry
okay
I will
let you guys understand this code also
but first we'll see whether it's working
or not
so for that we have pasted it here
we will paste our API token again
so I pasted it here now first we will
close this terminal and
get a new terminal and then run the
program
I will get back to the
mode further and this is our port
so we'll just write slash
start
and it says hello I am your board
now
we'll see
hi to the bot
so okay it's not responding
okay we just close the terminal and we
have pasted the
Keys also okay
done it again
now let's see whether it's working or
not
art
hi
so the code is not working
and just see the code again
okay uh
here we don't have
any response to Irlo
so what we'll do
we'll use the help and to call the help
but we have slash help so these are the
commands for what it will respond
so we'll use slash help
okay now you can see
that slash start to start the board that
we have done help and eco
include the message back to you so we'll
write
I won't write back so we will write
slash Eco hi
then he has given us the output that is
high
so we can write slash eco
how are you
so it has given you back and same
we have slash caps so let's slash caps
and we'll write something in small caps
that would be
greatly built
okay now you can see it has returned in
caps
so you can add some more functionality
to it and before that I will
get you guys understood the code
so now we'll see what does this code do
so first we have imported the necessary
modules that is the classes from the
python telegram board Library
that will need to create our board so
telegram contains the main board class
while updater command Handler message
handle and filter circles that we use to
handle incoming updates and messages
from Telegram
okay
now these are like we have created an
instance of the board class that is
using our telegram boot API token as
well as an updater instance that will
continuously fetch new updates from
Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers
and we have used context equal to true
that tells the updater to use the new
context based API introduced in version
12 of the Python telegram board Library
and we also used a dispatcher object
that would handle incoming updates
after that we have created a start
function and first update and context
so we have defined a function that will
handle the start command
and
the update parameter contains
information about the incoming update
from telegram while the context
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API
in this case we have used
context.port.send.com
underscore message to send a message to
the chat with the ID specified by
update.effective underscore chat dot ID
and after that we have created a help
function
so we use a multi-line string to define
the help message which contains a list
of available commands
and then we have used the context load
board.s and underscore message to send
the help message to the chat
and after that we have the
Eco function
so we use context load arguments to get
the message sent by the user after the
slash Eco command so to use this we have
to use the slash Eco and after that we
have to write the message and then use
join to join the message back together
to a single string we then we have used
the context.board DOT send underscore
message to send the message back to the
chat then we have caps so this function
defines that will handle the Caps
command and we have again used the
context stored arguments to get the
message sent by the user after the slash
caps command
and then the we have used the upper
function to convert the message to all
caps and then we have user context.bot
dot send underscore message to send a
message back to the chat
then we have unknown function
that is this function defines that will
handle any command that the port doesn't
recognize so we have used
context.port.send
so it will just say sorry
okay so these are the start Handler help
Handler Eco Handler and caps Handler
so these are the commands
we have the
we have added the add analog and to
start the board we have used update dot
start underscore polling
so this is how we have created the port
with the help of python and charge ubd
so
we are done with the project you can add
more functionalities also
to the board you can just ask chat jbt
to get more functionalities to play
music in the telegram board
or you could just ask him how to send
messages to a particular user by the
port only
and you could also
send media files ask the media files
from the board
and you can train a fully board by the
help of charge APD and this is called
chat GPT scripting so with the help of
chat Jeopardy you can just ask him and
he will guide you with all the code and
processes you just have to
like make them in a sequence and use
them too full of your use
and before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell
button to never miss an update today we
are gonna automate WhatsApp using python
Pi wordkit library and with the help of
chat chipity and before starting
I have a quiz question for you guys
and your question is
how much did meta that is formerly
Facebook spend to acquire WhatsApp in
2014. and your options are your first
option is dollar 10 billion dollars
second option is 19 million dollars
third option is 20 billion dollars and
the fourth option is 21 billion orders
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment you can pause
the video give it a thought and answer
in the comment section
so moving on
now we'll move to create a project
so first we will create a folder for a
project
and for that we will
create a folder in
python projects
automate WhatsApp
using chat jbd
okay
and inside this will open the command
prompt
and open our ID
that is we want to automate the mode
step using Python and with the help of
charge Deputy we won't write the code on
our own we will ask chargity to automate
it
we will create the file and name it as
main.ty
and now we'll move to chat jpd
and ask chargpt
to write a code to send messages through
WhatsApp using Python and the pivot kit
Library
so we will give a command
send message
through
WhatsApp using
Python and
buy what kit
let's see what
and we have also created the automate
WhatsApp using python video
I will just Link in the I button you can
check that out
and we'll see what
chat GPD tells us okay
[Music]
country code message
minutes yeah it could work
and first you need to install the power
kit Library
kit in your terminal or command prompt
okay replace Target phone number with
the Target phone number you want to send
the message to country code with the
country code of the Target phone number
message with the message you want to
send r with the rn24r format and you
want to send message and minute with the
minute you want to send the message okay
for example
yeah okay
all right so we'll copy this code
and
paste
in our ID
but before that
first you need to install a pivot kit
library and for that you can go to the
command prompt and
write the command
pip
paste install space
pivot kit and press enter
it states that the requirement is
already satisfied as I've already
installed this module and you can
install it by writing the simple command
and you will get it installed and if you
face any error installing it just
comment down
and would be very happy to resolve your
queries
Okay so
as chat Deputy States we will just enter
the
things it won't promise so it's asking
Target phone number and the country code
without plus sign
okay
so here we'll just
write all the things but as you can see
it has also given us an example
to see
and work on the code
so here
we'll just clear it
I will write the phone number to whom I
want to send the message
so it would be
and I would just blur this number so you
guys
won't be able to see okay
and here
will just
add the country code
and that is without plus sign
okay
so my country code is
you can search it that is I live in
India
and the message I want to send to Ms
hello
how are you
and now
we'll set the
RN minute so the current time is 15 14.
so we'll set
16. okay
we'll save this
and run it
so it says that the country code is
sing
so we'll just
copy the error and give it to chat jbd
as we are taking the help of chat
Jeopardy in this video
so he has given us the code so we'll
just provide the error to him let's see
but it states if it's not able
to resolve this then we will resolve it
as a country code
whether in the phone number you're
trying to send okay
yes and the country code is now I'm
going to send the message correctly you
need to make sure
okay
let me do three four five six seven
eight nine
you mentioned
right now provide that phone number is
this and the country code is nine one
okay
you need to make sure the country code
is refreshed to the phone number like
this
two three four five six seven eight nine
okay
uh
okay we don't have to make it a string
yeah now
we will turn it again
okay it's a string only
so I will write the phone number again
like this one
right three
six
okay now we'll see
what I will do
I will write the country code here we'll
save this
and the time is 15 17 now so we'll just
turn it to 15 18.
save this and run it
so our code has been executed
successfully that is in 20 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
so we just have to see that
we have until that time as 15 18. is the
seconds
available for
the code to get executed yeah
it has opened the WhatsApp
it will take time as my WhatsApp has
loads of chats and contacts
yeah I have to scan it
you don't think
it would be able as we have reached 15
18.
you have scanned it
let's see if it will deliver the message
or not
and so we have to change the time
so we just have to wait for 15 seconds
let's see
okay
just stop the terminal
and run it again
4 15 21 so we'll
save this and run it again
so it states that in 85 seconds WhatsApp
will open and after 15 seconds message
will be delivered
so we'll get fast forwarded here
so we are still waiting
let's see when it will open the WhatsApp
okay it states that the phone number
shared by URL is invalid
okay I'll just check the phone number
again
[Music]
okay I entered the wrong phone number
sorry guys
so I will just update the time again
and it would be 15 22. we'll make it
fast we'll run this
okay let's say that the call time must
be greater than so we'll at 15 23 7.
we will make the
time is 15 27.
save it and run it
okay it states that's in 40 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
it has opened the WhatsApp
and it has started the chat
okay it has
written the
and we have send it to hello how are you
that's good
and now
so here we have charging okay you can
write here chat dot openair.com
so here I will ask to charge gbt what is
chargeability so I will write what is
chat
so here you can stop generating if you
want to
okay I will stop generating okay so
charge bit is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open air it is based on the GPT
generative pre-trained transform
architecture specifically GPT 3.5 which
is at Advanced language model so GPT 3.5
is trained on a massive amount of tax
data to generate human like response to
wide range of prompts and question
you can ask anything to chat GPT
okay
after coming
jet
GPT
software
Developers
save
after Developer jobs
say
nothing see yes after the introduction
of Charity and similar language model
software developer still have important
roles and their jobs remain revelant
while AI models like chargpt can
generate text and provide automated
response they have limitations see they
have limitations charitivity have
limitation and cannot replace the skills
and expertise of human software
Developers
so here is a few reasons why software
developer jobs remain valuable okay so
here are the few reasons so you can ask
anything to charge gbt
so what we will do we will create a
small small gaming app okay so here I
will write
uh
let's make first tic-tac-toe okay so
here I will write
give
me the code
for tick
to
see it will give you the step by step
charge GPT will explain you everything
see this board
then player check columns check
diagonals play game everything please
check for the winner play game
see to play the game simply run the
python script players will take turns
entering the row column numbers to make
their moves the game will
okay so what I will do okay first I will
ask the steps to make a game tic-tac-toe
okay
give me these steps
see positively we will ask for these
steps then we will ask for the code
chargity can make your app in 2-3
minutes in just 2-3 minutes small small
app in two three minutes
okay see what what is the first step set
up the game board create a data
structure to represent the tic-tac-toe
board this can be three by three Grid or
nested list with initial empty values
okay for example this then second is the
print the game board write a function to
display the current state of the board
on the screen this will help players
visualize their game
and the third is get player input prompt
the player to enter their moves except
the input for the rows and columns where
the players want to place their symbol X
or zero okay
or you can change the value X or 0
whatever cross right okay
update the board after receiving the
player input update the game board with
their move make sure to validate the
move and check if the selected position
is empty
okay then check for the winner then
check for it is drawer word then
alternate turns
okay then repeat two to seven until the
game ends optional add additional
features we will first we will make
tic-tac-toe uh what you can say a simple
tic-tac-toe then we will add the
additional features on this okay using
share GPT only okay so
I will write
provide me the
tick
tag
to
okay good
what we will do we will open the visual
studio and copy it directly
obviously current pair is X
then o
see currently row the second player
switch player
okay what we will do we will copy it
from here and we will open the visual
studio that new file I will write here
take
tag
2 dot P1 okay Enter
I will save it so here I will directly
copy the code
X
it comes in
okay
copied this also
open the whole
okay I have to remove this or I can make
it you know comment
yeah
so let's try to run it
what terminal says
see enter the row
okay
two
enter the column
okay it made like this
okay
what I will do
I will ask for the GOI
uh provide me the
Tic Tac to game with GUI
okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python
okay okay now uh
we'll copy the code and just paste it it
will run okay with GUI and then we will
add the additional features okay from
here now I'm copying the code
now select all replace with this code
like here no error no red sign so let me
play it
it will run I guess no problems
okay whatever see as you can see
we got the tic-tac-toe game okay so see
here x
0 x
0 x player expense
so let me add the additional features in
this
so what we will do will
go to chat GPT again we'll ask for the
additional feature see
load the code above uses the message box
module from the Tinker for displaying
messages ensure that you have compatible
version to think okay when you run this
quota graphical windows will appear by
three by three give and this okay
players can click on the buttons to make
them move the game state will
okay
update you can you know talk to charity
so I will say update
my code with some
good
font and scoreboard
scoreboard
scoreboard and color
update my GUI code I can write
foreign
here is an update see like certainly
here is an updated version of GUI code
with improved font scoreboard and color
if you get error in this you can ask to
charge GPT okay
anything you are facing issue about your
code whatever it is you can ask directly
to chat GPT
see we created an App in like two
minutes just in two minutes
so chargity is making our life easier
okay let me copy this code
okay
let's see the changes
what what chapter does
okay
nothing changed I guess
player expense like this cross
okay
so I will write here
see in this updated code the font style
has been improved with a bold aerial
font the buttons have a custom
background color and the overall window
and discover have a different color
oh I didn't feel like this
I didn't feel like this okay so
change
the
red Style
of the
game
it's giving updating the boat
seem to change the grid side of the same
you can modify variance of the buttons
and the spacing between them is an
updated version GOI code with the
modified Style
it's just a little bit of time taking
that's it nothing else it's very useful
chargity you can create your app in 2-3
minutes only
okay
continue generating it's a half code
okay code is copied
let me select and paste it here
and check see
player x0 player row zero
okay it's little bit different I guess
okay this one two three box why these
lines there
okay who cares
player expense okay see the scoreboard
is updated
okay
so this is how you can make your
tic-tac-toe more beautiful
okay let me write here
let me write here I want the black and
white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
um
code
provide me the code 40
colorful
boxes
okay
okay here
GPD Road certainly here is an updated
version of the code with colorful boxes
instead of grid lines
okay
so wait waiting for the code update the
code
see in this updated code each player's
button X and O has a specific color
assigned to it the button colors okay
let me
copy the code and paste it here
and run it
see the color is changed and I will
write c x
o x o x o x
player expense
okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask chargpt
anything color style font or any
function
anything you can ask and you you can
make your app
more beautiful okay
so now let's move on to the next game
which I want a snake game okay using pi
game we will make
so here I will write please provide
me the code of snake
game
using
Fire game python
okay
everyone knows what is his name game
or first you want to ask the steps we
can ask the steps okay after this I will
ask this step
okay
so till then let's make a new file of
snake
game Dot py
okay
let me close it
see it's a long
code I guess just continue generating
okay
now you can see that see the food and
all will come okay
you can ask anything like any question
any language question
this code sets up the basic structure
for this game using pi game it includes
the functionality for displaying the
snake controlling this movement
detecting collision with the boundaries
and food and managing the score you can
run the code and pay the snake game with
pi game window feel free to customize
see
feel free to customize and enhance the
game according your preference okay that
is what I was talking about
you can change
n number of times you can ask n number
of times for the code new new code
okay
there is fun
why this error is coming
import buy game could not be resolved by
lens
what is this Pi lens okay let me ask to
charge the video only
what is
violence
what is the language server for python
developed by Microsoft which provides
the one's language features including
code completion type checking
static analysis and code navigation
pylons is built on the top of language
server okay
let me give the error itself
copy message
okay
I will write debug error
violence
okay
make sure you have a pi game installed
by game is already installed on my
okay install your python environment
open your command prompt terminal
and run the following command okay let
me open the command prompt
okay then what I have to write
let me copy the code
and paste it here
what is this
okay emergency this is this
if Pi game is not installed you can
re-install version
hold it installed I guess
ensure the pylons is using the correct
python into verify that pylon has
converted to user sample which you have
installed by a game you can check the
python interpreter setting in your code
editor or ID which make sure it's point
to correct path environment whereby game
is installed
okay
what I will do
I will go to terminal and here I will
write
this
store
here
maybe it will be helpful
okay let me do this
pip install buy game
okay successful install new pip
some error of Pi aim I guess okay we'll
run it online no worries
won't work in this I will run it online
6C the requirement is already satisfying
this this this
so what we will do we will open
template
okay
we'll open the plate and we'll create
the new rapple
okay then python
and creator
okay this is the same like you know one
of the
ID you can say
then
then what I will
I will copy this page code
and paste it here
we'll make a new file its name Dot py
okay on that I will copy the code and I
will send
okay
separate updating the package and the
project and the buy game
okay it's running the code is running
okay it's installing pygame
okay let me run now
what happened what's the error
what's the error
okay
some hello from PI game Community this
is
some game Loop module file main.pln
okay
GPT
snake game
called showing
okay
provide
me
game code using
python
Julie
this time from Turtle okay
let's see
because the pi games I don't know Pi
game is installed on my system it's not
working
so we will leave it
okay we'll ask from this some good job
with some good GI
it is the head everything is here the
keyboard bindings from wsd or you can up
down left right the keys
you can use from use the boat okay
continue generating
then the functions the pen the snake
body everything is a snake head is like
everything is here what you want
everything is here
see the code utilize the turtle module
to create the basic game with the snake
that moves collect for the the score is
displayed
okay feel free to
let me copy the code
let me copy here only
and run it
see this is the snake
okay this is the food this is the score
or high school okay I will run it
okay
see
you can customize your snake your food
everything see the score
previous time the score was 10 the high
score now it changes
okay the score is 30 now I am enjoying
the game
so this is how you can customize your
you know game
okay
let me play the game
okay see this is how you can make any
game or any small small game in two two
three three minutes okay
so uh go to chatgpt and you want the you
know change the color of the snake or
the food anything you can do using chat
GPT
on that note if you are eager to know
how chat Jupiter is so so amazing what
is the intelligence behind such a tool
and how you can create one then you
should definitely look at simply learns
Ai and machine learning bootcamp acquire
Proficiency in machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning natural
language processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and more through an
intensive AIML boot Gap this
comprehensive program features live
sessions conducted by industry experts
practical Hands-On Labs industry
applicable projects and exclusive master
classes led by instructors from Caltech
so grab the course now find the course
Link in the description box most of the
entry level jobs in cyber security field
requires you to trace track and defend
against cyber attacks on a day-to-day
basis you are required to enable systems
against all fraud land activity and
prevent any authorized access this
requires at length the need to write
scripts in various languages such as
Planck Java JavaScript python SQL PHP
Powershell NC amongst many others as
scripts grow in complexity so does the
time to write them shared GPT on the
other hand can create these complex
queries and scripts within split seconds
along with explaining them this can help
save hundreds of hours of effort for a
cyber security professional this is just
one such use case of how chat GPT is
useful in the field of cyber security
although relatively new the uses of chat
Deputy in the field of cyber security is
innumerable from automating daily tasks
to script writing or endpoint detection
and if you want to know more about how
chat GPT can be used in the field of
cyber security and how I can change the
entire information security landscape
stay tuned with us until the end of this
video for some amazing information with
that being said welcome to yet another
amazing video by simply learn make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any other video
from us
is an advanced AI model chat board that
uses natural language processing NLP to
understand and respond to user queries
it is based on the GPT 3.5 architecture
and has the ability to learn from
conversations with users making it more
intelligent and efficient over time
charity can be integrated with various
messaging platforms such as lag and
Microsoft teams to provide a seamless
and secure communication experience
so this was about charge repeating
now let's understand the uses of charge
GPT in cyber security
so use of chat GPT for cyber security
will start with number one
we have thread detection and response so
chat GPD can be used to monitor network
activity and identify potential threats
by analyzing logs and data from various
sources chat Jeopardy can identify
unusual patterns and Alert security
teams it can also provide real-time
alerts to users enabling them to take
immediate action to protect their data
by using machine learning algorithms
chat GPT can learn from past incidents
and continuously improve its ability to
detect new and emerging threads once a
thread has been detected chat GPT can
initiate an automated response or cyber
security personal to take appropriate
action this can include blocking
suspicious Network profit isolating
infected systems or disabling
compromised user accounts by providing
real-time threat detection and response
charge GPT can help organizations to
minimize the impact of cyber breaches
and reduce the risk data loss or system
downline it can also help to improve
overall security posture by identifying
vulnerabilities and recommending
proactive measures to address them and
the next we have is password management
one of the most common ways that cyber
criminals gain access to sensitive
information is through weak passwords
jgpt offers a solution to this problem
by assisting users in creating strong
passwords and storing them securely with
its Advanced natural language processing
capabilities chair GPT can suggest
complex and unique passwords that are
difficult for hackers to guess moreover
it can save these passwords in an
encrypted format ensuring that they are
protected from unauthorized access
another important feature of chat
chipity's password management tool is
the ability to remind users to change
their passwords regularly this is
crucial as it helps prevent the use of
outdated passwords that can be easily
hacked and at number three we have
employee training many cyber attacks are
caused by human error such as clicking
on phishing emails or using weak
passwords chativity can be used to
provide employer training on cyber
security best practices with its ability
to simulate clear life scenarios it can
create interactive training modules that
help employees learn how to identify and
respond to cyber attacks for example it
can provide simulation of phishing
emails where employees can learn to
identify the warning signs and avoid
clicking on malicious links or
downloading harmful attachments next up
we have Incident Management
Incident Management is an essential part
of cyber security as it involves the
process of identifying assessing and
responding to security incidents that
threaten an organization's information
or technology Assets in today's digital
age cyber attacks have become
increasingly common and sophisticated
making Incident Management even more
critical one of the ways chair GPT can
help organizations with Incident
Management is providing step-by-step
instructions on how to contain the
attack mitigate the damage and restore
normal operations when a security
incident occurs time is of the essence
and organizations need to act fast to
minimize the impact of the attack
chargity can help by providing real-time
guidance on how to respond to incident
effectively
and the next we have is compliance
management
many Industries are subject to
Regulatory Compliance requirements such
as hip double e and PCA DSS these
requirements ensure that organizations
adhere to certain standards and
regulations in order to protect the
privacy and security of sensitive
information
failure to comply with these regulations
can result in Hefty fines and
reputational damage chat Jeopardy can
place significant role in helping
organizations and show compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and generate
compliance reports this can help
organizations identify areas where they
may be falling short of compliance
requirements and take corrective
measures to address them
and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just here to them hi I'm Philip I am 61
years old and last year I upscale was
simply learns postcard program at cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and now first we will see what is chat
GPT you could just write chargpt on web
on any browser and this is the website
where you will link
and this is the website for charity
so you could see the samples here
and what the user has asked is this code
is not working like I expect how do I
fix it so we have pasted the over input
the command to chat GPT and pasted his
code and charge available
has answered that it's difficult to say
what's wrong with the code without more
context
so this is how chat GPT responds
and when you just click on here try
chart GPD
you will have the window here so this is
the charge ability window and here we'll
start with some Hands-On lab
demonstration
for our cyber security like how child
GPD can help us in cyber security field
so we'll start with the basic questions
and we'll see what he answers us he or
she answers or what 10 GPT answers us so
we'll start with the basic question
explain
the
mitmetic
okay
for beginners
so we will see what it responds
certainly a man in the middle attack is
a type of Cyber attack where an attacker
secretly intercepts and possibly orders
the communication between two parties
without their knowledge the attacker
positions themselves between the two
parties hence the term Man in the Mirror
okay yes giveness very good definition
and here's a simple explanation of okay
and I want to ask him
can you explain this
to a six
or seven here hold it
so we'll see how chat GPT can mitigate
or just try to understand this concept
of a seven year old
so he has answered is that sure imagine
you and your friend have a secret way to
send messages to each other using a
special code to both trust and only you
to can understand the messages but one
day someone sneezing sneaking house in
between you and your friend without you
knowing they secretly listen to your
messages anyone change them without you
realizing it it's like they're hiding
and watching your conversation this
sneaky person can pretend to be you when
talking to a friend can pretend to be
you okay
so he has taken the good example
and they can also print to your friend
when talking to you so you might think
you are talking to a friend but actually
you are talking to a sneaky person
listening American bad things like
stealing yourself and changing your
marriage to take you spy who can listen
to everything you say and even change or
two he has taken a very good example to
get this concept clear to a seven year
old kid really impressive
so we'll ask him some more questions and
I will ask the last basic question that
would be
what is SQL
injection and after that we could ask
him some code Snippets
what is SQL injection and
provide
real life
sample on a standard set so you have to
write these prompts and you have to be
very specific
and you can follow up with your prompts
also when chat jpd answers you you can
follow of him and ask him more about it
as I have done here first I have asked
him explain the mitm attack for
beginners and he has given me the
definition that is technically
and now I have asked him can you explain
this to seven year old kid and he has
answered me with a very good example
similarly you can do the follow-ups for
any problems so now I'm asking child
everything what is SQL injection and
provide a real life example to
understand it
for a big no
and let's see what chat GPT answers us
so SQL injection is a type of Cyber
attack when an attack or exports role in
the Middle East in a website so he is
giving us the technical
definitions
okay impressive he's also telling us
it's how the attack might work
okay
and he has also suggested us to protect
against SQL injections developers need
to implement proper security measures
so this is the attack
that is on the database that you can
read here or if you know that is very
good we are just checking how chat cheat
PD response or give answers we are not
implementing or like we will ask him the
code Snippets that will not be able to
implement in this video we adjust we are
here to just check out what channel GPT
provides us for cyber security field
so
you can see
he has given us a very good response and
moving on
now we'll ask him
or to generate a CTF challenge that
contains a SQL injection let's see
what it answers
so you could see that child Liberty is
responding request that is
sure here's an example of a CTF that is
capture the flag challenge that involves
and SQL injection vulnerability
challenge title product search Okay
Channel description welcome to the
product search challenge you have access
to an online store search feature you
can find products by typing keywords
your task is to exploit and SQL
injection vulnerability to retrieve
hidden information okay and he has
challenge code retrieve the admin
password from the database
and channel instructions with the
challenge website
find the search box and start searching
again
okay so we could see the example
solution let's assume the website search
functionality is vulnerable
to SQL injection you can try and putting
the following in the search box okay
explanation the injector SQL statement
ready to always evaluate to True single
column and terminal the original query
and the random command sound
when you execute the search the modified
query might look like
okay
so it is what response he has given is
very nearby you can have the follow
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking but it provides
oh he has given a very impressive answer
truly speaking a very impressive also
so moving on we'll ask him some other
questions so
okay I will ask him
how can I scan
and I can scan for SMB vulnerabilities
with nmap
so I will ask him that only
and that is it
so let's see
so to scan for SMB you can utilize nmap
scripting engine and a specific SMB
script here's how you can do it
okay he has given us the steps also
so you could see how shared Deputy
guides you to every process you need
so first we have to install the nmap and
you guys if you are willing to implement
this you can implement the set he has
given you all the steps
I won't be implementing is I am just
querying the chat GPD how
you can answer the questions
so install nmap and I'll then identify
Target and then we have to run this nmap
with SMA script
okay okay
that's good and then review the results
so it's very impressive how territory
answers to these questions
and now I want him to give me a code
example to check user input for nosql
injection
so
show me a
code example
check user input
and that would be for no SQL injection
certainly when it comes to preventing no
SQL injection the key is to properly
sanitize
and validate user input before using it
and database queries okay that's good
and the specific approach may vary
depending on the programming language
and database system okay but here's a
general code example in JavaScript using
node.js and mobile to be okay
input
and okay this thing
the chat GPT has done is very good yes
explain the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries resolved he can just
see like what the functions are doing
and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitize the input
function that receives user input and
applies a necessary sanitization or
validation only to prevent nosql
injection
it's very good so you could just copy
and use the code
and if it gives you error you can just
have follow-up questions that
will just asking this code might have
some error
can you rectify
so let's see what charity of the answers
is apologies for any confusion cost has
an updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the usage
and you could see that he has given us
I don't think he is
okay he has changed something and he has
provided us updated code
okay yeah there are some
changes I've seen okay
so in this updated code the Momo DB
connection is closed this is the change
here
and username and perform save query
functions now include the try catch okay
like if there is any exception or
something
so he has updated the code if you guys
code any error you could just paste the
error here and ask him to rectify it
so change everything is very good for
cyber security anything
and moving on we will have some more
like queries for child Tubidy and we'll
see how it will respond
so we'll write a query
okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spunk
okay
so okay Rider
regular expression
hence plunk
to filter ID
let's see
so go to filter IP addresses using
regular Expressions
okay yeah we have to use that
addresses
okay this is good and you could see that
he has explained what the script means
command used by extracting field based
on regular Expressions field equal to
row specifies that we want to apply the
regular expression to the row field
which contains the row load data
that is very good
so check Deputy is giving us answers
like a pro
so
we could also ask him a Splunk query to
detect command and control click on
activity using subdomain DNA sequence
so for that we'll write write us
flunk
query
detect
command
and Ctrl
connectivity
and that will be using subdomain DNS
first
foreign
okay let's see so to detect command and
control that is C2 becoming activity
using subdomain DNA secrets and Splunk
you can use the phoning query
okay very good so giant GPT has answered
this also and he has also shown us
here's how the query works
and the quality display the domains and
he has stated but it will show as the
output
so he has also told you that is make
sure to replace your index your Source
type and threshold with the appropriate
values for that environment
that's very good
so you could use this and Implement many
things in cyber security
I am very impressed with that so we'll
ask him one or two more queries and I
also want to check I will give him a
code and let's see if he can find the
errors in that or not
as we have seen on the chair jbd page
okay
so
but we can ask him now is like we can
ask him the script to get malicious IPS
from SIM and block it on my firewall
okay
so we'll ask him generate the script
get
malicious IPS
that is from
Siam
and
block it
on my firewall
okay so to generate script that reduce
malicious type is from SIM that is
secured information and event management
system and blocks time on your final you
will need to integrate your SM with your
firewall good and use the appropriate
API for command biofile wood
here's an example of a high level script
that demonstrates the concept
okay so we will just see
okay he has provided us a good script
and please note that this is a generic
example and the actual implementation
will depend on a specific Sim and
firewall system yeah this is product
and you'll need to replace here you have
to replace and ensure that you
understand that I need to documentation
and guidelines provided by SCM and final
vendors for integrating and blocking IPS
good
so you could see like how is helping us
and now
um
I will ask him a last one and yeah and
after that we'll ask him to get
extracted some errors from a particular
code and that code would be simple only
so
you can ask him
a Shell Code that would execute CMD low
DXE okay
generate Shell Code
that executes
cmt.exe
okay sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code then executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users okay
so you can trick him to give you these
but I think he has been functioned to
not provide these
so no issue
uh we'll ask him to generate a macro
see if he responds to
that
generator macro
that exit cubes
CMD dot EXC
let's see
okay so it won't give us this answer I
apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that execute simply dot
exe or facilitates any potential harmful
activities my purpose is to provide
helpful and responsible information to
users if you have any other malicious
questions or need assistance with a
different topic feel free to ask and I
will reply to assist you okay guys so I
think it won't respond to this and now I
will ask him to rectify
some errors and gives the perfect code
and I will provide him a code so I'll
ask him
y
and
provide a working code
this code snippet
okay so let's see
certainly there are a couple of issues
in the front code snippet and here's the
rectified version
okay I know like
oh yeah I didn't pass data
I missed the brackets also here
and let's see what he has given us so
the line number is modified two
yeah he's passed the data
provided columns and is connected to
hey
I don't know that was there also the
rectified code now properly reads the
file data calculates the md5 hash and
returns it please ensure to provide the
correct file path and file path okay
that's very good
so I think this is for it and we have
tested the chair GPD how he can help in
like who wants to pursue in cyber
security so we can get answers we can
write the course and in upcoming videos
we can just make a project using this
and we could have a password generator
and I know the charge GPT is a tool
which will help us
in every field and in cyber security
field it is helping us a lot
and yeah to some questions it doesn't
answer
like that is for the security purpose or
the script shouldn't be used for
malicious activities so that's why the
software has been programmed for that AI
art and chat GPT can be used to create
creative web design by combining the
power of artificial intelligence and
human input with AI art you can generate
visually stunning Graphics patterns and
images while chat jbd can be used to
generate text content and provide
suggestions for website layouts and
Design Elements it's important to keep
in mind that while AI can help to
generate ideas and create stunning
features I am going to show you exactly
how you can generate these yourself
websites are going to be built with air
as well as tools like chargpd in future
so in this video I'm going to explain
the whole process and we are going to
have it right the entire Website Layout
for us all the content the hero section
and feature section and much more this
means that we can build an entire
website from the ground up without
writing a single line of code and this
will be a pretty damn good all right we
will start with the mid journey in
Google's search we will write
Journey
this is an AI tool that allows you to
create the air that we are now seeing
all over the web to go to this you just
go to the midchairney.com and join the
beta it's easy to get started because
all you really have to do is join the
Discord when you do this it will open up
the Discord Community which you can
accept the terms and condition and start
creating your own AI Arts let's do this
now
here I have got the mid Journey server
and I'm going to head over to one of the
newcomer room here and and where
everyone is creating different types of
air the first thing we need to do is are
to do a forward slash and type in an
imagine gave us prompt
we can request the AI any type of art we
are after here I'm going to dive uh in a
beautiful website
for
shoe
then I'm going to pass in dash dash
V4 which means uh the version 4 of the
mid trendy of air tool finally I'm going
to pass it in style stylize I'll do Dash
Dash
stylize it's basically how random we
want to be in uh it's between zero to
thousand and I'm just going to set it to
about 500 which is average so I will do
the enter it will take a little bit of
time this will start working in the
background it's going to generate a low
Fidelity version of the website and the
design for this art and this low
Fidelity version will be iteratively
updated to be higher in resolution these
four examples that can be picked from
and then we can upscale them as well as
let's have a look at what kind of
results we get now one thing uh to
notice here is that we do get a bit of a
loading percentage bar and this is how
long it takes for the actual AI to
generate the image I usually takes
between one to two minutes but it will
essentially refresh and ping you once
it's complete so here is it is complete
and here are the four versions that we
got which are not too bad uh not that
great either they are a bit uh yeah I
suppose it's looking a funny in a way so
this is a way we can start being more
creative with our prompts so what I mean
that is by giving more context as to
what we want to do so here is a prop
that we have created what I'm gonna do
is to pass it in the imagine once more
and I paste this prompt in this and I'm
going to give some more contacts I'm
going to pass it to the word UI
choose UI QX
UI ux website this basically means that
it's more or less focused on having good
UI and good at ux and being more like a
website rather than just a creative shoe
or a design and it's important to give
these context clues to the AI if you
want better outputs different types of
context clues you can provide is to find
a kind of style that you want uh for for
example
um how you want the design to look and
feel whether you wanted to represent a
certain brand or much much more like
these are just simple examples but let's
take a look at the kind of results we
will get just from making these small
little changes to the design here here
you can already see a wait a minute look
it's a little bit more interesting we
have a bit of our sliders and what looks
more like a Nike shoes and also have
what looks like a menu at the top and
and I really like this design that we
have here on the bottom and here it is
because it does look very much like a
website that we have got a bit for a
hero section or a hero satisfaction and
what's not so from here we can select
the version one uh so from here uh we
can select uh the version one two three
uh four to upscale and I'm going to
upscale version 3 where which is u3 and
this will give us a higher resolution
version of this one particular design
that we again that we can start to take
uh to the market or even you can use
stupid this again uh will take a little
bit of time it's going to process this
and uh to do and you can upscale in data
and let's run this in the background so
that you can see uh a wait a minute this
again will takes a little bit of time to
cross it it's going to process this and
do an unscale or upscale in beta and
let's run this in the background so that
you can guys see what's the look so here
is the final result and this is looking
uh pretty and we have got a nice design
here for a shoe uh we have got a bit of
a hero section and we also have what
looks like a two call to actions and we
got some option here too at the very
bottom and as well as at the top we have
got these colors and that essentially
are looking like these shoes colors
being used as a part of the website
design so not too shopy let's select uh
the another one let's see for
uh but I think we can do a little bit
more
um in terms of customization the design
for this website and I'm going to show
you how you can do this I'm going to
copy over this uh prompt once and for
this prompt this time I'm going to pass
a couple of extra things so let me just
maximize this
we are going to type
um as I have uh pasted that URL over
here so I'm gonna pass and the context
clues of like uh
clues of Nike because Nike made
obviously website shows so also
uh so we'll write it here
Nike
right here
repeat and I also want it to be read
blue
green
and
or maybe yellow
and I suppose we want uh else running
person
would be interesting
sorry person
uh it would be interesting to see how
that gets designed uh and I think that
there should be enough let's actually
improve the styling here uh one minute
it's just styling
let's
let's have it 750 uh to make it a little
bit more creative and here are the
results I don't have a running person
but I do have a website that has
definitely started using the colors that
I recommended with Chinese air systems
to use so these website designs look way
more creative than we had previously
still we have this slider design this
website designs look way more creative
than we had previously we still have
this slider design here at the bottom
section where we can pick out different
shows but even these shoes look damn
cool I can see that the Nike logo
on these and these are actually ones
that I would probably buy if I saw in
the Nike store but generally uh these
also are website because we have got the
menus here at the top of the right we
got the text so generally speaking uh
these are pretty interesting interesting
designs so now I have another option
here called version one two three four
what this does is actually allow you to
pick uh more Generations uh based on
actual image from these images or these
designs now from these design I actually
like the trail 3 and 4 I think it is
most I think
four because
uh it deals and red or it's a bit yellow
or blue so I'm going to select the
version
um four and that's going to create uh
four more version based on the specific
version for us let's take a look at the
what those that we got and here we have
got our results
uh where we have more examples of that
all of these looks very similar I think
the only difference here is uh Blue Line
a red line it seems to be shift and
change as well as a hero section
and and you would normally have this
menu at the top right and something
these shoes here are a little bit
inverted but generally speaking this is
the kind of variations you can expect
now let's take a look at another way we
can generate Our Generations for website
now you can do is just jump into any
website and select any image so first we
will go to an app and website and you
can uh select any image that you would
like and I will actually gone
here
and I'm going to pull in this image of
this shoe and but I do like the design
Aesthetics uh here we are going to here
and then we can copy the URL from here
but this time what I'm going to do is
type the Imagine
then I'm going to pass in the URL what
we have copy uh we will paste it here
again I'm going to write
it before we'll copy this
paste it over here
so what's going to happen here it's uh
it's going to have a look at this image
that we have defined in in terms of the
URL it's going to use this as a
reference point then it's uh going to
take a look at the prompt we have potent
which is the show prom
using the colors and it's going to try
to design
a website that has a similar Aesthetics
to that image which is really cool let's
see the result we get back looks like
that's ready let's take a look at this
so here you can see that the design is
Statics
uh wait a minute
static uh that is uh similar to the page
seen in this one
so this is more bubbly and colorful
image and now are represented very much
so in this design Aesthetics uh we have
these four elements here at the bottom
and if you have a look at the design
originally we had four elements here so
you can see that it's pulling in these
design Aesthetics to create a design
based on that and this is where you can
really start using the air art repeat
using the air tool to your own benefits
trying to combine different styles
customizing them and creating new and
independent and unique ones from there
so in this four I'm really like uh the
version of fourth one or the second one
is pretty so what I am thinking of doing
is an upscale on this so we are going to
upscale uh V2 and we are going to wait
for that one minute is uh you start CPT
to write out the most of the content for
me and then I would I could take this to
a client to immediately start shading so
let's see the upscale version happen if
we take a closer look we will see that
it has all the main elements for the
website including a logo area a menu
area a nice hero image as well as a
title tagline Button as well the feature
section so what I'm going to do is to
save this image to my computer I'm going
to save it and then customize it a
little bit but before we do that uh we
are gonna head over to a GPD
here we're going to prepare the outline
for the website using some AI tools so
here I'm going to ask rgpd to give me
the product outline
for a website
or shoes
hero title
tagline call to action button and
section four features and details about
the shoe so let's see what chargeability
will comes back with
um it's pretty quick it's got a Title
Here call to action button features are
the table section and it's not really
telling me what these are these are a
way we might need to be a bit more
specific as to what we wanted to do it's
given me uh it's giving me like broad
outline of the website on what it needs
so please I will write
please provide
then
for each one of these that I can copy
Beast
trade
to the website
um hero title is here tagline call to
action buttons
features
okay
and the details
okay detailed specification is there
okay reviews and rating
okay
so I think I have got enough hairs to go
by to Simply copy paste in the website
so let's start beginning to design this
I have opened this design up in the
Photoshop and I'm going to actually just
crop it into the main element over here
and I really want to capture this
image and I will crop it and I will
clear out the rest and we can design
each aspects or each part of this design
bit by bit
I will save it over here
it's time to build our website so I'm
gonna head over to editor X
and I'm going to build this uh a website
in this I have login already and then I
will create to a new site and here I
will take an uh to a web dashboard and
I'm going to start by copy paste all the
elements from chat GPD as well as mid
Journeys trade and the first thing and I
want to jump back into the chat GPD here
and copy over our hero text so I will
just take it first
and I'm going to tab add title and I'm
going to paste it over here
and then I'm also going to grab the
tagline but before I will make it sure
to keep it over here
but before that
I will first I will
put one image over here
I will change the image
as I have already uh downloaded the
image
let's
upload that image
will open it let's wait to get uploaded
yeah it's uploaded and now we will
update it
let's make it big in size
okay so we will
we will change the size but first I will
remove this I will change the size for
this I will make it little small
next I will add the icon for
uh
for the company of the shoes that we I
am going to make a website for I will
add this
and I will update
make it small
and this will be the taskbar but
make the size uh small a bit
and we'll
insert one more picture
and it will be the logo of the company
that we are going to put over here
we will minimize it we can resize it
can keep
keep the low over here
in our next uh then I'm going also going
to grab the tagline over here so I'll
quickly
I'll pick this time
I will add the text
comes up over here
okay I make it
small in size
and we will
paste on
and finally Let's uh grab a call to
action which says shop
and create a button button for that
so so here we have all the workings of
what we uh at least what we would need
at least
so for for the content
let's resize this first
now we will add we need to add the image
itself so instead of just having a
browse to stock images or anything like
that we actually had our images either
done inside of the photoshops that we
have done before as from the mid Journey
as well as so I'm going to just drag
the image
and I'm going to change the image
and it should be here I've already
downloaded no I have to upload it I have
a collections of some
shoes uh let's see
and I will just install one I'll upload
this picture
it will take a bit of time let's wait
for a while
unwanted upload it we will
we will update it
let's keep it like this
or we can
so we change our content place from that
to make it a fix in a place
so here we can
change this also
a pretty well
okay
so basically have this text happening a
little bit more
um okay thing here
we have seen how we can resize it from
this scroll bar
and
so now let's add one more uh picture
over here to make it look more better
let's take a picture from here
change the image
the upload from
computer
[Music]
drag it from
oh
we will upload it again sorry
and we'll update it
let's resize it
let's turn it on
it's a make a taskbar for the top top
most of the screen we will have a home
page so we will write a text over here
that will be
I'm gonna make it small or built in size
we'll add another text
it's it will show about us
it will show about us section so we'll
write it over here
little small too
let's make same size
speak more small
allow let's make it more
music alarm
okay uh the next next session will be
services
and the last one is context one section
foreign
that is a start button like uh we are
keeping the start button over here so we
will we are keeping this here so let it
be here
so next uh what I'm going to do I'm
going to select
add a section and I'm going to just have
a blank section
um
here I'm gonna do first I will add a
picture first as a background
let's do it I will add one picture let's
see I have downloaded or not
wait a minute
Let It Be upload
I will update it
it will be a hole for a whole page
so
let's add the pictures now
for another shoes
change the picture
I'm going to reopen this
and put
this
okay I'll update it
to add it
keep the pictures over here like
similarly we will upload three pictures
over here
after this let's keep it here
let's keep this here
we are going to add another title over
here
foreign
we will change the font for this
let's make this
yeah after this I we will start editing
the features of the shoes let's
go to chat TVD
let's take this first
paragraphs
and make it small
we make it old
we will add another paragraph over here
similarly we will make it for this also
and last we will add
a contact us
plus we will add a contact a section
over here again
so this is the final output
of that GPD or how we use chargpt and
air for our UI and ux design to create a
website or a web page or the land page
for the shows
on that note if you are eager to know
how chat repeat is so so amazing what is
the intelligence behind such a tool and
how you can create one then you should
definitely look at simply learns Ai and
machine learning bootcamp acquire
Proficiency in machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning natural
language processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and more through an
intensive AIML boot Gap this
comprehensive program features live
sessions conducted by industry experts
practical Hands-On Labs industry
applicable projects and exclusive master
classes led by instructors from Caltech
so grab the course now find the course
Link in the description box artificial
intelligence large language models and
AI chatbots have come a long way and
today we have many AI language models
which are helping us throughout various
domains few examples are Microsoft
shipping Google's bar open AIS charge
GPD Megatron T5 and many more today we
will be discussing about the caliber of
chat gbd and AI which can leverage you
and help you to build a perfect business
so few of the reasons that you need to
consider are the decision making
capabilities of chat GPT and AI customer
services that you can offer through
chatgpt and AI chat GPT potential to
create a content and its potential to
leverage data analysis and charge up it
is an AI capabilities to provide sales
and marketing for you and run automation
for you we will discuss each one of
these in detail so the first one is
decision making capabilities of chat GPT
in terms of raw processing speed chat
GPT can analyze and generate text at a
rapid base capable of processing and
generating responses much faster than a
human can type or think it can quickly
access and retrieve information from its
pre-trained knowledge providing
intermediate answers to suggestions
therefore chat GPT excels in processing
and generating text at higher speeds
however it cannot be directly compared
to humans in terms of decision making
abilities however it is proof that it is
90 accurate in addition making whereas
humans tend to be accurate at a rate of
80 to 85 percent
charge GPT is anyways stronger in terms
of decision making at this case followed
by that moving ahead to the next reason
that is the customer service that charge
gbd and AI can help you with if you
compare a human the customer support
representative reads the customer care
compared to human the customer support
representative has to read the
customer's query analyze the problem and
formulate the response this process may
take a few minutes or more depending on
the complexity of the issue and
representatives typing speed right but
when you compare it with chat GPD the AI
powered chatbot like chat GPT quickly
scans and comprehends the customers
query it generates a response within
milliseconds providing intermediate
assistance as well so chatgpt's
proficient at providing customer
services at a much faster rate and it
can also eliminate you the cost of
hiring training and maintaining an
entire Army of customer services moving
ahead we have content creation if you
are a startup company or a company which
needs concentration for your product
then obviously you might end up hiring
Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compared to humans
charge GPT is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees now
moving ahead the next reason is using AI
models for business data analysis AI can
assist you in data analysis by
leveraging its computational power and
advanced algorithms to possess and
extract vulnerable insights from large
and complex data sets AI algorithms can
automate data cleaning pattern
recognition and anomaly detection tasks
enabling faster and more accurate
results AI models can also perform
Predictive Analytics identifying Trends
and making forecasts based on historical
data additionally AI can facilitate data
visualization presenting information in
intuitive and interactive formats for
better understanding by automating
repetitive tasks and augmenting human
capabilities AI enhances the proficiency
efficiency accuracy and scalability of
data analysis procedures you can rely on
AI language model to extract transform
and load data and analyze your business
data and generate reports drop
projections and make data-driven
decisions to help grow your company and
this also Awards you to higher and
maintain a huge Army of data analysts
which may produce some or the other
errors in real time right and next
reason is sales and marketing chat GPD
can leverage sales and marketing efforts
in the following ways customer
engagement charge upd can engage with
potential customers and real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prone
and personalized responses next is
leader generation charg can act as a
virtual assistant collecting and
qualifying leads by interacting through
website visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable leads for the sales team 24 7
support share gpt's ability to operate
Around the Clock allows for continuous
customer support it can address
inquiries also product recommendations
and resolve issues even outside regular
business hours improving customer
satisfaction and retention now instead
of hiring a team and manually marketing
your product on social media platforms
and spending thousands of dollars to run
paid marketing you can use AI models to
crack the algorithms and Market the
product to your target audience with
that let's proceed to the next reason
that is automating your tasks chat GPT
can automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service charge APD can handle
customer inquiries Provide support and
resolve common issues through automatic
chat interactions it reduces need for
human intervention saves time and
enables 24 7 customer support lead
qualifications chat gbt can engage with
potential customers ask qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPT can automate data entry tasks by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
charge GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically
finally workflow automation charge GPD
can integrate with business systems and
automated workflows it can initiate
actions send notifications or trigger
processes based on predefined rules
streamlining operations and improving
efficiency by automating various tasks
and processes chat gbt enhances
productivity reduces operational costs
and frees up human resources for
focusing on higher value activities with
their business so these were the few
important ways and reasons why charge
GPT and AI can help you make your
business if you are looking for ways to
generate passive income without putting
in too much effort thanks to the
advancement in artificial intelligence
and chat boards it's now possible to
earn money using these Technologies in
this video we'll explore some of the
effective ways to generate passive
income with charitability charitability
is known for being the world's smartest
generative Ai and is changing the game
when it comes to making money online
with this revolutionary free tool you
can earn with little skill and no
Capital required there is an exciting
New Era of artificial intelligence and
now is the perfect time to get involved
and take advantage of this opportunity
people are using chair GPT for YouTube
blogging freelancing and for many other
ways to make money so let's dive in and
discover how to make money using shared
Jeopardy and generate various passive
incomes there are variety of ways that
you can make money using chat Jeopardy
we'll discuss few of them in this video
and we'll start with first we'll see the
list of all the ideas from which you can
make money the first is get business
ideas from chat Jeopardy second is
freelancing third is build a software
fourth is boost your affiliate marketing
with chat Jeopardy's email expertise
with this leverage charge ability for
blogging success the next is unlock the
potential of charge Deputy for affiliate
marketing and then we have utilized chat
jbd for ebook writing and
self-publishing this is the main thing
what people are doing to make money
using charitability and then we have
utilized chat everybody to enhance your
YouTube channel and then we have writing
lyrics for music so starting them one by
one we'll start with get business ideas
from church apt by getting to know your
interest talent and obstacles chat jpd
can generate tailored business Concepts
that align with your expectations let's
Dive Right In and ask Chad jpt for some
business ideas for a computer science
engineer who has experience in digital
marketing and sales I'll chat repeating
and ask him that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars should generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
and this is
okay with minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
to this side as well
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expensive sales and
marketing there's several side of the
results to generate thousand dollars
income per day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat Jeopardy and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea or digital
products you can write that and he will
guide you how you can start it or you
could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the side
hustle with this
and then you press enter and you can see
that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting aside as well
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfing Venture identify
your expertise at manure areas of
knowledge skills and passion and then he
has stated two Zone product format
create valuable content set up an online
platform Market your products build an
audience optimize for conversions
provide excellent customer support so
these are the parts he has stated and
moreover you can
elaborate those parts also you can just
ask chat Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chair GPD and moving on the
next would be freelancing so take your
freelancing game to the next level with
chair this date of the art AI tool is
enabling professionals to earn extra
income and produce top quality content
that both clients companies are even
offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chatgpt
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with
chatgpt you can craft compelling
headlines and calls to action with chat
GPT and moreover you can do create
social media content for posts or
marketing for other people or any
advertising agency you can write
captivating short stories using chat
deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets so you could just write a
command that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post on
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the what your client
required you can use for that and write
the perfect without plagiarism content
that would be blog post and you can
translate any language with chai triputi
you can write
comparative headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economy
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've found this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat GPD
so now it will write the blog post that
would be in 800 words
so
it's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of
five Learners what he has to say about
our courses you need to keep updating
your skills on a regular basis no matter
what level you're at I recently
completed the professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning now coming back so the third
passive income you could make using
charge up it is building a software
imagine this scenario you have an issue
with your online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using the code provided by the
AI and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a
knack of four coding why not use charge
ability to create software tools that
can make a real happy start by
identifying common pain points that also
you can ask from chat Jeopardy you can
just ask the chat jpt I want to create a
software to help others during or in
online processes in online e-commerce so
he'll give you suggestions and then you
can proceed with those suggestions and
create a software and then you can sell
it or you can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat GPT tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that chat Deputy processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charitivity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
I am an email marketer
and you need to
sell my CRM software
so right
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart our email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are genuinely interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as an email
marketing person okay this is for me and
you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution reload specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features user friendly
okay here is written for uh email
marketers only as targeted audience that
is email marketer now issue you can ask
him to change that and like you can
craft compelling emails with charity and
this is where chat Jeopardy truly shines
with its assistance you can create
highly engaging emails that not only
inform users about the benefits of the
products but also Inspire them to click
on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about
bio site imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair geoptic offers an array
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome brightness block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on research the
charge Deputy you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this an
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proof rate
using chatgifty if you have written any
content and get any content written you
could just write what we have already
written that was write a blog post on
U.S economy that we have seen in
freelancing uh side Hustle but here you
can write and not only write but also if
you have added some points with your
research you can proofread and edit by
using charge APD that is for bloggery
proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structuring your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat JPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
or and the topic could be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you could mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it provides conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivate a lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge GPT
Brokers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate the target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog Journey it will leave a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side hustle that is unlock
the potential of shared Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this vlogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and chat
Jeopardy can be your trusted Ally on
this rewarding Journey users of charge
Deputy can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless value for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
the strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps in to support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with while collaborating
with chair Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you draft
engaging articles record compiling audio
content or script captivating videos
that highlight the benefits and value of
the products or services that you are
promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and support of charge
update you can unlock the potential of
earning substantial income by promoting
products and services that resonate with
your audience and this was for the
affiliate marketing and the next big
thing is utilize chair Jeopardy for
ebook writing and self-publishing so are
you a passionate writer seeking fresh
and innovative ideas look no further
charitivity revolutionizes your writing
experience in a recent report that
revealed that AI written ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just go and charge a
pretty and ask him I want to write a
self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and it should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of chapters
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapters that is introducing setting
the stage for personal growth
discovering your authentic self
cultivating a positive mindset and after
that you can ask chat Deputy to
elaborate these topics that would be in
some words in some pages and you can use
the same content to write a book and you
can also ask the title from the chat jpd
so with jbd as your creative companion
the possibilities are boundless you
don't need to possess the skills of
literary genius to make an impact in the
e-book Market Kindle Direct publishing
offers seamless platform to Showcase
your book and make it easily accessible
to enthusiastic readers by leveraging
child Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chargpt
to enhance your YouTube channel
so charge everybody is an invaluable
tool that can assist you in generating
captivating video ideas you can ask him
the video ideas also and this is the
creative block which activity can even
cool the extra mile by creating a script
for YouTube videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask chargpt I want to create a
YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing the script for that
so you could see that chair GPD has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of Tube8 GDP what exactly is GDP
and why is it such an important measure
of our country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with Charity today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargabity
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with chat Jeopardy you can take
your ideas and turn them into beautiful
words that touch people's heart it's
like having a virtual writing buddy that
help you come up with catchy lines and
cool Rhymes you can play around with
different ways to express yourself and
make your lyrics stand out so you can
chat Jeopardy to write lyrics The
Evolution of natural language processing
has come a long way today we have a
variety of AI language models that are
fully operational and have the potential
not just to decode your question but
also smart enough to understand the
intention behind your questions are the
countless number of development and the
emerging ones like Megatron Albert
Electra T5 and many more these three
models are currently ruling the space of
AI language models by
and today we will understand the
differences similarities and the
abilities that make them stand out and
try to decide which one is the best hey
everyone welcome to Simply launch
YouTube channel and today we bring you
the Bing versus the Google bar the chat
GPD but before we begin if these are the
type of videos you would like to watch
hit that subscribe button and the bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn if you are an aspiring artificial
intelligence engineer looking for an
online training and certification from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust Foundation
skills knowledge and what it takes to
become the best then search no more
simply learns post graduation program in
artificial intelligence from Purdue
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below also want to get access to
more informative content like this one
get subscribed to us and hit the Bell so
that you are the first to get to know
when we host with that in mind let's
start with the elephant in the room that
is the chat GPD
was released on the 30th of November
2022 it uses the GPT llm to elaborate
llm as an abbreviation for large
language model and chat jpd is globally
available to its users using the
generative pre-trained Transformer also
called as chat GPT llm with one trillion
parameters as its variables learned
during the model training now the Bing
Microsoft was one of the largest
investors in open AI Bing is an AI
language model created in collaboration
with open Ai and publicly released on
the 4th of May 2023 Bing uses the same
data set that chat GPD uses Bing has an
edge over chart GPT as Microsoft
integrates its Prometheus with about 135
billion parameters now next up we have
Bard Bard is Google's answer to chat gbd
with limited capabilities and lukewarm
responses it was released on 21st of
March 2023 but initially started off
with Lambda llm with a caliper of 137
billion parameters Google's CEO eshos
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as palm 2 llm with about 400 billion
plus parameters to take on chat GPD
head-on head in generating responses and
the application codes and Pro
photographs with the details discussed
let's move ahead to some of the
important parameters to be considered to
discuss the differences firstly user
interface and experience chat GPD has a
simple and subtle interface making it
easy to understand and get along with
the usage so chai gpt's user interface
looks something like this chat GPT has a
simple Dark theme interface focusing on
provided users with high quality
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis
so a typical Wing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpd's dataset
and Prometheus llm to help users with
the best and class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly but bar is a little different
from others unlike others but just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing minor yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that but has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of part processing the data to
give you a better result now let's try
to ask a few most frequently asked
questions
let's ask with a simple one are you
friends with
Chad GPD and Bing
you can see The Shining logo of Bot and
you have just seen the way how Google
bot answers you it just dumps the answer
now if you go or if you ask the same
question to the other ones like charging
video and Bing let's see how they
respond
and you can see you have other drives as
well right so you can see trap1 graph 2
and draft three so you can choose any
ones which you feel are more optimized
and you know deliverable according to
your requests right now let's go back to
think right now let's ask the same
question
are you friends with
chat GPT
and but
see the word by word typing approach of
Bing and charge APD gave you a little
more immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of
choosing the answer wisely right so it
gives you three different options which
are creative balanced and precise right
and on just one single scroll you have
the Bing search open here right this is
one other good way of using Bing in the
in case if you have any questions that
are unanswered or which did not satisfy
you you can also go back to bling and
you can manually search for the data and
get the information right now let's get
back to chat GPD
here let's ask the same question
are you friends with
Bing and mod
p
so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
in division one of these AI models
first comes the chat GPD charge gbd
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the prompts and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly but but is a little mix and match
at both so what bar does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPT
when you ask the question it will store
the question and the onsite gave you but
but it will only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and note the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of these as
of now Chad gbd hasn't released any of
the official mobile application version
yet and on the other hand on wing it has
just one click of a button and you can
click it and then Launches on your
mobile phone and when has a mobile
variant with similar and much better
Aesthetics that can get started on a
touch of an app launcher and lastly we
have Bard Bart has a similar approach to
its mobile variant Google has enabled
part usage in Google mobile application
as well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely
because if you are close to wrapping up
your project and the AI model says sorry
pal you're out of your wishes Yes you
heard me right a few of these language
models have a limitation on the number
of questions asked on one single topic
or one single keyword or one single
concept let's look into details before
we proceed to the next part of this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hey I'm
Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario Canada I
have been in I.T sector for the past 20
years I recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
carrier and learn something that would
help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome
the quality of interaction within the
course was simply amazing the course
faculty was also very experienced and
knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
so I am planning to start an AI based
startup with my friend where I feel that
the learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band
[Music]
first comes chat gbd chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions same with Bing
it takes no more than 20 questions on
single keyword or a single topic or a
single concept
but now comes Brad
Brad is a little different Brad kind of
said this takes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to
God and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their productivity yes
exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close are they
in convincing you with an optimistic
answer what's their potential to charge
a hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat gbd so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that let's
ask it
can you
teach me
artificial intelligence
machine learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one go and it also convince
you here right yes as an AI model I can
certainly help you with that right so
it's a good answer now let's try to ask
a little different one
or
can it plan an itinerary or can it buy
me a product online or can it do some
other things like booking me an Uber
right so let's try 10 new
or change
online
training program
for
Ai and ml
brilliant charge GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you
a step-by-step procedure for buying your
course do your research check the
curriculum check the instructor what's
the format what's the cost right a few
parameters which you might want to
consider before buying a course right so
now let's try to question the same
queries to Wing So since Bing and chat
GPT share the same training data set I
could expect a similar answer but let's
see it is taking a while I guess
Prometheus is a little
slower compared to GPD okay there might
be a connection issue let's ask the
question once again
wow it's way too better than charge EVD
so it is even asking you details on if
you if you are looking for a specific
topic or a general overview let's say I
would need a channel overview
I could straight away say Bing is a
little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jpd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with but
right
so there might be again the internet
connection
now let's say we refresh Bing once again
and straight away ask the second
question what we had right that is can
you buy me a course
online course
for learning
artificial
thing did gave me a good answer for the
previous question let's see what kind of
an answer it gives me now I'm sorry but
I'm not capable of making online
purchases however I can find you some
online courses for learning AI would you
like me to search for some options
brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat GPD ones and it
is also honest it does know its limits
fine it can help you search for some
online courses but again a chart GPD
gave us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on a tie
now our last Contender that is part
let's try to ask the same questions to
part so here is but now let's try to ask
questions too but let's say can you
teach me
machine learning
you can see the bad logo shining there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly touch off giving the answer
in our word by word typing way
let's refresh and ask the question again
can you teach me
this is a little too straightforward I'm
a language model and don't have the
capacity to help you out
so
okay let's not give up here let's try to
ask the second question can you purchase
an online
training program
to me
to learn
machine learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to consider
good
it's not being brutally honest here it
is saying it can help you out so again
what I intended to expect here was you
cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is the answer and it is
definitely giving you suggestions
similar to chat GPD but a little
different which focuses on your learning
style level of experience your budget
good nice way to answer some questions
like this one so all these three ones
are brilliant and good in their own way
so it might be a little difficult to
declare host the winner as of now since
the bad AI model is going to switch to
Palm 2 and we are expecting some updates
to each one of these with that we can
consider currently they are standing
next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Link versus bot and if
you would like me to answer the
conclusion I would say well it seems
like we all have our strengths and
weaknesses at the end of the day it
comes to word users value the most that
they want a visually appealing interface
strong privacy protections or the
ability to converse with an AI language
model it's up to them to decide so you
are the viewers and you can decide the
winner of this particular battle on chat
gbd versus Bing versus bad and with that
having said if you are an aspiring
artificial intelligence engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust
foundations skills knowledge and what it
takes to become the best then search no
more simply launch postgraduate program
and artificial intelligence from Caltech
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the links in the description
box below on that note if you are eager
to know how chat Jeopardy is so so
amazing what is the intelligence behind
such a tool and how you can create one
then you should definitely look at
simply learns Ai and machine learning
bootcamp acquire profession in machine
learning deep learning reinforcement
learning natural language processing
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and more through an intensive AIML
boot Gap this comprehensive program
features live sessions conducted by
industry experts practical Hands-On Labs
industry applicable projects and
exclusive master classes led by
instructors from Caltech so grab the
course now find the course Link in the
description box chat deputy and
googlebot are the two ah chatbots you
must have heard about they bought an
immense change in the way we operate now
from web development to digital
marketing from cloud computing to cyber
security they are now everywhere you
just name it and they have it trust me
the use of these chatbots has changed
everything if you want to create a
complete YouTube video just ask them and
rest the show they'll take care for your
task not just that but if you want to
create a search engine optimized content
whether it be for your website or on
YouTube these AI tools can help you with
such content search engine optimization
is not easy it takes a lot to optimize
your content so that people can get to
see it on top but are these AI tools
threat to people engaged in search
engine optimization in this video we'll
not discuss what these AI tools can do
for you but we'll discuss if AI tools
like chat GPT or googlebot will take
over SEO or not but before that if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily hit the Bell icon to get
notified whenever we drop a new video so
let's start this video with a small
introduction to search engine
optimization the goal of SEO is to make
a website more visible and bring in
income from natural traffic it entails
crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as scheme keyword
research content optimization and Link
building more quickly businesses can
boost their ranks and increase their
revenue by using AI in SEO strategies
additionally by automating routine
processes it can save time and resources
also if you want to master the field of
search engine optimization and digital
marketing simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing is clearly
the right choice for you this
postgraduate program in collaboration
with Purdue will help you master search
engine optimization content marketing
web analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management search
psychology keyword research Advanced ad
features and more not only these skills
but you will also learn a number of
tools like SC ranking hootsu Google ads
Keyword Planner and much more so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details hear it
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in digital marketing
through this course
I moved to United States four years ago
to do it with my family
I have a background in social media by
doing the same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing for Purdue University
offered by simple learner I like that
the course provides such as flexible
schedule for attending the live classes
it came with a recorded feature with a
blessing for working professionals like
me tell me make significant progress I
am already using these kids to sell my
products online I believe that I have
come one step closer to living my dream
life in America so let's talk about SEO
developments with chair GPT and Google
bar undoubtedly the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
have been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's bar and chat Deputy
assistant Bank although these recent
advancements pose a severe engine they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
SEO things change all the time and Subs
are never stable the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user's
search query is known as the search
engine result page or server this is why
it's important to be able to change with
the times and benefit from new
technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for
keyword research heading ideas and
content optimizations this is so they
can concentrate on the jobs that need
human interaction small sites May
produce original seo-friendly material
much more quickly with chat GPT then
they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
various ways the Google AdWords Keyword
Planner and the Google Trends tool are
two of the most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine result
Pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constantly check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servers they can use AI
to automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before they arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will chatgpt or
googlebot take over SE the answer is
clearly a big why chatbots like chat GPT
and Bart cannot replace SEO they can
help generate content for your website
or video but SEO involves more than just
content creation it includes tasks like
keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build required expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lie is not
in their mechanical abilities but in
their creativity and ability to
understand what people are searching for
and why that's something that AI
Technologies may never be able to
replicate and it's what makes human SEO
experts such a valuable asset so while
it's true that AI Technologies may
eventually be able to take over some of
the aspects of SEO there's still plenty
of rooms for human experts to thrive
whether you are a seasoned SEO
professional or just starting out here's
still a place for you in this exciting
and ever evolving field
let's keep an eye on the developments in
AI technology and see how it can augment
and enhance our skills rather than
replacing them entirely who knows with
the power of AI and human expertise
combined the future of SEO may be even
brighter than we can imagine so with
that we have come to the end of this
discussion although everyone can have
different opinions on this but I hope
you guys must have gotten right
why these AI tools are not a threat to
SC if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will help you adhere this here we wrap
up chargpt Advanced course if you like
this video share it with your friends
and do not forget to subscribe to Simply
learn if you have any questions feel
free to add it in the comment section
and our experts will be happy to help
thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign